Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Laschet wollte ja über Ostern nachdenken, weiß man da schon was Neues?
Ich glaube, die Auferstehung ist dann am Montag oder wann, ne? Rosenmontag ist die Auferstehung, oder?
Rosmontag.
Ich kenne mich mit Ostern nicht so gut aus.
Politik Nummer dreihundertsiebenundachtzig vom fünften April zwanzigeinundzwanzig
die Osterruhe ist äh auch bei uns fast eingekehrt. Wir konnten uns dann aber doch noch zurückhalten und dachten uns, ähm,
Eine Sendung machen wir dann doch noch. Wir müssen uns da bei Jesus wahrscheinlich äh,
für entschuldigen, weil es war da nicht irgendwas mit Podcasts äh äh verboten über Ostern.
Irgendwie Gotteslästerung ist verboten an Ostern und tanzen, ne? So war das,
ich kenne ich kenne mich wirklich mit. Ich weiß nur, dass es immer anstrengend ist, am Karfreitag die ganzen Filme zu gucken, die man nicht gucken darf. Das ist ja eine ganze Menge und da muss man sich ja dann
nächstes Jahr Bürgerpflicht, sich dann dahinzusetzen, die auch alle zu gucken bei offener Tür, weil damit's auch, ne, keine geschlossene Vorführung ist und so. Schlimm.
So ist das. Totaler Stress und jetzt auch noch ein Podcast aufnehmen. Nun ja. Wir haben äh heute auch noch eine Gäste mit dabei und wir begrüßen Eva Eva Wolfang. Hallo.
Hallo, schön euch zu hören.
Ja, schön äh dich zu hören, Eva, wir dachten uns äh für das heutige Thema und die heutige Sendung steht so ein bisschen unter einem Schwerpunkt. Ähm
bräuchten wir nochmal ein wenig Unterstützung. Vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz was zu dir sagen. Du bist Journalistin
Wissenschaftsjournalistin kann man wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ne? Oder ist das schon zu dir schon zu spezifisch?
Ja, also Wissenschaftstechnik, Reportagejournalistin, so würde ich sagen, ist die die Mischung. Speakerin, Moderatorin, neuerdings auch immer öft.
Genau, Journalistin, die was von Technik versteht.
Damit schon ganz gut eigentlich, ja.
Ja
Genau, du hörst dich sozusagen allgemein der Technik und technologischen Entwicklung im Großen und Ganzen auch verschrieben zahlreiche äh Preise auch in dem Zusammenhang äh eingesammelt über die Zeit.
Bist aber so äh vom Haus aus Kulturwissenschaftlerin. Das ist so ein bisschen deine Perspektive, mit der du auf die Welt blickst, richtig?
Ja, lustigerweise zieht sich diese Perspektive so ein bisschen durch. Ich meine, das klingt jetzt für das vielleicht ein bisschen in die irre Kulturwissenschaftlerin, die Perspektive, aber tatsächlich das habe ich studiert, empirische Kulturwissenschaften und seither.
Ähm finde ich Geschichten in Zusammenhängen und Themen und Daten und das ist im Prinzip das, was mehr auch lernt, wenn man Kulturwissenschaften, Studierende, Geschichten finden.
Und die richtigen Menschen finden, die man sprechen muss und dann die Geschichten so zu erzählen, dass es spannend ist für andere. Ja, von daher doch, das passt schon.
Und wie willst du dir deine Geschichten aus? Was, was, was zieht dich an?
Oft erfahre ich.
Irgendwie zufällig von Themen und ich glaube, das ist echt ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, den viel zu viele übersehen, also am Rande von Konferenzen beispielsweise, Gespräche zwischen Tür und Angel, das ist auch der Grund, warum wir gerade so echte echte Vor-Ort-Konferenzen ganz wahnsinnig fehlen, weil diese.
Dieser Ort zwischen Tür und Angel, den gibt's halt so selten online, den gibt's eigentlich nur in der virtuellen Realität. Und auch da sehen wir uns viel zu selten.
Ja, ansonsten kriege ich immer öfter auch Informationen einfach von von Menschen äh zu zugesteckt oder ähm mitgeteilt, die sagen, guck mal, das könnte spannend sein und dann habe ich irgendwie auch so ein bisschen eine Antenne, glaube ich, dafür.
Auszuwählen, was also wo hinter sich was wirklich spannendes verbergen könnte.
Was waren denn so deine deine Lieblingsthemen der letzten Jahre?
Ich habe ich habe viel zu letztlich Cybersecurity und Authentifizierung und solchen Geschichten gemacht.
Ich finde, dass dieses Thema total ähm unterschätzt wird in der Öffentlichkeit, in meinen, so mein bisschen mein Unique Selling Point ist ja,
komplexe technische Themen in der Öffentlichkeit zu erklären,
als meine Verantwortung an auch eben auch darauf hinzuweisen, ihr könnt mit eurem Verhalten ganz, ganz viel zu Sicherheit im Internet beitragen, dazu online Cyber Security letztlich.
Ähm angefangen von so blöden Dingern wie Passwörtern. Und natürlich dann habe ich immer parallel die Forschung begleitet, weil natürlich blöde Dinge wie Passwörter auch einfach von Natur aus blöd sind, weil die Anforderungen an Menschen stellen, die.
Nicht äh.
Nicht erfüllbar sind, ja? Denk dir ein kompliziertes, einfach nur merisches Passwort aus und zwar ein anderes, für jede deiner vierhundertfünfzig verschiedenen Apps und Anwendungen im Internet. Das geht halt einfach auch nicht. Also, solche Sachen.
Ich viel, die Knackpunkte finden an an Technologien ähm und gucken, was was muss die Gesellschaft jetzt entscheiden, damit's gut wird, künstliche Intelligenz, habe ich.
Unglaublich viel dazu gemacht in letzter Zeit klar, weil natürlich die Anwendungen auch immer.
Werden in unserem Leben und und äh letztlich unser Leben viel mehr bestimmen immer mehr bestimmen und auch natürlich auch Probleme und Fehler mit sich bringen, die man, glaube ich, wenn man's richtig macht, zu großen Teilen ausmerzen kann und dann muss man natürlich noch entscheiden, was soll überhaupt damit machen? Und auch da.
Immer die Öffentlichkeit muss muss da informiert sein um um da richtig drüber entscheiden zu können.
Ja und letztlich, klar, das Herzblutthema, was ich lange schon jetzt habe, ist, wie gesagt, virtuelle Realität, einfach, weil ich gemerkt habe, dass das so ein Raum ist.
Und das habe ich witzigerweise schon vor der Pandemie gemerkt, als wir uns noch durchaus auch im im echten Leben treffen konnten, im analogen Raum. Äh das ist ein Raum, der am ehesten dem echten Leben nahe kommt und wo man wirklich Menschen.
Begegnen kann, auf auf einer Ebene, die sehr, sehr ähnlich ist, wie im echten Leben. Und wo viele von diesen Interaktionen, die uns jetzt fehlen, hier auf Zoom oder Skype.
Doch möglich sind. Auch bisschen ansatzweise Gespräche zwischen Tür und Angel. Also ich war auf ein paar Konferenzen jetzt auch in der virtuellen Realität und war tatsächlich ziemlich begeistert, dass dass man da so ein bisschen,
auch nachempfinden kann. Wir gehen zusammen in eine Ecke und quatschen mal oder ich höre jemand spricht am anderen Ende des Raums über irgendwas, was ein Stichwort, was mich interessiert und gehe da einfach hin und rede mit.
Das ist ja was, was wir leider gerade seit einem Jahr zu großen Teilen gar nicht machen können.
Virtuell und und wie real meinst du? Also mit so einer Brille dann auf oder.
Ja, also am liebsten gehe ich schon mit Headset in die VR, weil's einfach noch viel immer siever ist, also wirklich Headset und und Kopfhörer und dann hat man das Gefühl,
Ich bin anderswohin gebeamt, weil das funktioniert wahnsinnig gut, auch weil unser Gehirn sich da sehr bereitwillig drauf einlässt.
So dass man wirklich manchmal auch ganz vergisst, dass der biologische Körper echt gerade in meinem kleinen Arbeitszimmer ist, während ich durch irgendwelche wilden, virtuellen Welten spaziere und spannende Menschen treffe.
Aber es geht auch immer besser mit Desktop. Also da gibt's jetzt und da hat, glaube ich, die Pandemie einiges beschleunigt. Es gibt einige Welten, wo man sich eben.
Auf eine Art dreidimensional durch den Raum bewegen kann oder zumindest mit mehr Dimensionen, ich weiß gar nicht, ist natürlich trotzdem zwei Ideen mit so einem Desktop ist, aber mit mehr Dimensionen als auf Zoom.
Eben auch, also ich war auf einer Poster Session zum Beispiel, auf einer Konferenz, die in so einem Raum war.
Mit war das gemacht und da konnte man eben genau dieses, man hat ihn eben diesen special Sound auch, also so den den räumlichen.
Ton. Man hat Menschen gehört, die weiter weg sind. Die waren leiser. Menschen, die nahe waren, waren waren lauter und man kann flüstern. Also solches, all so Sachen sind ja auch total wichtig für.
Ähm Interaktion für und Kommunikation.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich, also am liebsten gehe ich auf echte Konferenzen im echten Leben und treffe echte Menschen und da entstehen tatsächlich die die spannendsten Themen oder ja in der Mittagspause.
Irgendwem.
Ja und bei all der ganzen Virtualisierung der Realität äh ist es dann doch immer noch ganz wichtig festzustellen, ob man die Leute auch riechen kann. Im wahrsten Sinne des.
Ja, Geruch wird auch völlig unterschätzt.
Genau und ähm der Teil ist noch ein bisschen ähm wenig abgebildet in diesem Bereich.
Aber auch daran wird gearbeitet, ne? Also VR soll auch demnächst oder gehen natürlich gibt's das als Prototypen schon, ne, Gerüche zu transportieren.
Soll einem auch richtig stinken können sozusagen.
Ja, vielleicht kann man das dann auch weglassen, aber.
Sicherheitslücken in Systemen, die Gerüche produzieren, ne? Die werden auf jeden Fall interessant.
Die virtuelle Stinkbombe.
Ja, vorher war es nur eine.
Jemand auf eine Idee gebracht.
Okay, also man merkt schon, du bist hier auf jeden Fall gut aufgehoben bei dieser Verquickung einer intensiven Technologiebeobachtung mit ähm gesellschaftlicher Perspektive.
Keine Frage. Und du hast dich ja, wie wir auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten ähm auch mit den digitalen Lösungen rund um die Corona-Krise beschäftigt
Wann hat das äh angefangen, gleich vom Staat weg, hast du auch schon die Corona-Warn-App von Anfang an mit begleitet.
Also ein Stück weit, ich war ja in USA, das als Corona anfing. Ich hatte Fellowsche beim MIT, einen Wissenschaftsjournalisten, Fellowship.
Und war da noch bis Juni letzten Jahres.
Ganz spannend war tatsächlich, dass dieses dieses ähm Proximity Tracing, was ja so die Grundlage von der Corona-Warn-App auch ist, auch am MIT ganz früh,
damit gebastelt haben und die Idee hatten, dass das also schon alles, als wir alle dachten, äh Corona kommt auch nicht.
Doch in China schon da haben die angefangen äh an solchen Lösungen zu arbeiten, eben auch zu überlegen, ob das überhaupt funktionieren kann,
mittels, also letztlich, was das ja macht, ist mittels Bluetooth ähm Abstände zu messen oder oder Aggregat, was auf Abstände deuten lässt.
Ja und da das war ganz spannend, weil da schon von Anfang an eben auch dieses Stichwort viel äh ähm Privacy-Preservin, also wirklich Privatsphärenfreundlich, ähm dass es wichtig ist, eine Technologie zu entwickeln für contact tracing, für solche Fälle, die eben nicht.
Zu sehr Überwachungstechnologie ist, weil natürlich Technologie, die die sagen kann, wer hat sich wann, mit wem, wie lang und wo getroffen, ist natürlich nichts anderes als als Überwachungstechnologie und das fand ich ganz spannend, dass das schon.
Also in den USA, wo mein Klischee wirklich ein anderes war, wo Privacy nicht so eine Rolle spielt und Daten sammeln eigentlich immer wichtig ist, dass das von da schon so früh.
Groß diskutiert wurde und da gab's natürlich auch Lösungen, die mit GPS gearbeitet haben und so weiter oder Vorschläge.
Da wurde relativ schnell auch von vielen Forscherinnen und Forschern gesagt, nee, also so können wir es nicht machen. Wir können nicht jetzt hier äh ja, äh Zentraldaten sammeln und ähm.
Überwachungstechnologie entwickeln, die wir nachher nämlich nicht mehr losbekommen. Also so genau, so habe ich mich von daher schon auch recht von Anfang an mit solchen Themen beschäftigt.
Es scheint sich auch grade ein bisschen zu ändern, ne, in den USA. Ist der Blick auf diese ganzen ähm Datenschutzfragen. Habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, teilweise ja, also ich glaube, es ist noch natürlich wieder ein Filterblasen Ding, also diese MIT-Haarward-Filterblase ist natürlich auch nochmal eine, die sehr.
Fortschrittlich ist ähm und die die Probleme und Gefahren natürlich auch sieht.
Zumindest teilweise, aber insgesamt ja, also das wurde unglaublich viel auch dort über die DSGVO diskutiert, was ich auch spannend fand, mir war nämlich von hier aus gesehen gar nicht klar, was für eine Rolle.
Kleines Europa und unser kleine und auch Deutschland in den USA spielt.
Und die haben sich, machen sie wirklich sehr viel Gedanken darum und manche Bundesstaaten, Kalifornien, soweit ich weiß und ich glaube noch irgendeiner haben ja die DSGVO auch kopiert, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist echt eine gute Lösung.
Das wollen wir auch gern, so haben uns viele Unternehmen auch und das finde ich auch spannend, also wirklich globale, große Unternehmen haben gesagt, komm, wenn wir eh für Europa wegen der DSGVO einen eigenen, also eine eigene ähm.
Strukturen und Teile implementieren müssen, damit das Datenschutz kompatibel ist, dann machen wir's gleich generell so, dann ist es halt unser Produkt ist dann halt datenschutzfreundlich und da fand ich echt beeindruckend, wie viel wir.
Doch bewegt haben. Und das glaube ich wird oft auch unterschätzt, wenn Leute über die über die DSGVO schimpfen.
Nicht weit genug geht oder zu schwer äh zu interpretieren ist, zu viel zu offen ist und so weiter. Ich glaube, man darf nicht unterschätzen, dass die doch wirklich auch auf, ja, auch weltweit wirklich viel bewegt und das ist ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Allein schon, weil sich die Unternehmen ja ohnehin damit beschäftigen müssen, wenn sie den europäischen Markt unterstützen wollen und den der lässt sich ja nicht so ohne weiteres ignorieren,
Aber das mal bei der Corona äh Krise bleiben. Also du hast ja dann sozusagen das in USA
ähm schon mitbekommen, die ersten Überlegungen und dann vermute ich mal, wirst du dann auch schnell äh dir Entwicklungen in Europa auf die Spur gekommen.
Genau, es wurde ja dann ja und das witzigerweise war auch echt ein auch ein Thema in USA oder kam auch dort an, diese Diskussion äh und und auch andersrum, ne, wurde auch von dort, glaube ich, nach Europa, Deutschland getragen, diese Diskussion, wie kann man das denn.
Privacy freundlich gestalten, was wie wie geht denn so 'ne.
Dezentrale ähm Lösung und auch wie kann man eben dieses Bluetooth Proximity Tracing.
So gestalten, dass es, dass es sicher ist und funktioniert und was sind denn die Grenzen davon? Ähm da habe ich, den genau, da habe ich mich relativ.
In diesen Diskussionen, ne, die wir alle geführt haben, als es um die Corona-Wahl ging und eine Zeit lang. Es schien es ja so, als wäre es eine zentrale Lösung gibt. Ähm.
Ja und ich finde, da wurde es, da ist es erstaunlich gut gelungen, das Ganze noch zu drehen, nämlich eben mit mit einer öffentlichen Debatte, mit einem natürlich auch einem gewissen Druck.
Entstanden ist auch durch diese offenen Briefe, wo auch Wissenschaftlerin ja auch aus den USA mit unterschrieben haben oder vor gewarnt haben, eine zentrale Lösung zu bauen.
Und ich denke auch durch den
und und auch da kann man die DSGVO vielleicht nochmal hervorholen, aber so grundsätzlich, denke ich, hat sich ja auch bei den Konzernen in den letzten Jahren, also in den dominierenden Techkonzernen in den letzten Jahren schon die Problemstellung äh gestellt, okay
wie können wir quasi den Zugriff auf die Nutzer weiter äh reduzieren, um da nicht permanent am Pranger,
stehen, ne. Äh bei Apple ist es ja mittlerweile ist es eigentlich schon lange Zeit quasi Teil des des Marketings äh und der Grundidee äh so vorzugeben und Google ist halt auch langsam gedämmert,
und ein Stück weit vielleicht auch Facebook, aber die sind da wohl noch ganz am Ende. Das,
dass sie so halt einfach auch nicht weitermachen können und dass sie dass sie das einfach nur in Probleme bringt. Aber ich will gar nicht die politische Diskussion hier auf äh führen, sondern wir wollen heute ja mal den Fokus auf
die äh aktuell diskutierten Lösungen eines zweiten Schritts,
für für diese ganze für diesen digitalen Corona-Tasting-Support äh besprechen. Konkret wollen wir uns heute nochmal die Luca-App äh anschauen. Da ist ja auch eine ganze Menge passiert in den letzten Wochen und du hast ja da auch drüber berichtet.
Wo berichtest du eigentlich wenn du berichtest?
Also ich bin ja freie Journalistin, das heißt, ich schreibe für ganz viele verschiedene Magazine, Zeitungen und Online-Medien. Jetzt in dem Fall, Luca-App habe ich jetzt vor allem für Zeit online gemacht. Ich schreibe aber auch für technologische Interview, für.
Spiegel, Spiegel DE für Spektrum, Spektrum der Wissenschaft oder für viele andere auch, ja. Aber das war jetzt für die Zeit und Zeit online, genau.
Genau, also das war jetzt quasi die Realität des letzten halben, dreiviertel Jahrs und jetzt ist halt ähm,
das läuft sozusagen die Suche nach nach weiteren Lösungen und die ist ja auch schon umfangreich diskutiert worden. Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt erstmal so diese Problemstellung bevor wir dann auf die Luca App kommen äh auch noch mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen, was
eigentlich Ziel dieser ganzen Sache ist. Und dann gibt's ja, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, eigentlich.
Mehrere Diskussionen, die so ein bisschen miteinander verweilt sind und die, glaube ich, auch die Debatte grade so ein bisschen schwierig machen. Da haben wir auf der einen Seite die existierende Infektionsschutzverordnung, die halt für so kritische Bereiche des öffentlichen Lebens, wie die Gastronomie, eben diese
äh Vorschrift hat, dass Leute, wenn sie denn dann schon da sind, äh das protokollieren müssen und für das Gesundheitsamt
hinterlassen müssen, was natürlich ein riesiger Aufwand ist, was viele Leute auch nicht richtig machen und was vielleicht teilweise ernst genommen wird und teilweise nicht und wo man auch lange drüber diskutieren kann,
denn das am Ende so viel bringt
dann gibt's diese ganze Debatte um sonstige Treffen, die sie jetzt vielleicht nicht mit solchen registrierten Orten äh zusammenhängen.
Wie und dazu halt auch so die Forschung ähm eben Infektionsbereich, dass man halt gesagt hat, wir wir müssen diese
diese Cluster, diese Superspreader-Events besser erkennen, äh wie könnte uns denn das Digitale an dieser Stelle helfen?
Wie stellt sich jetzt diese diese Gemengelage für euch da? Was was seht ihr da jetzt eigentlich für eine Problemstellung? Ist das schon mal eine gute Strukturierung, wie ich das aufgestellt habe oder
Wie würdest du das sehen, Eva?
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist eine gute Struktur dann genau. Also was ich merke in meinem Bekanntenkreis, außerhalb und meiner Filterblase, dass ganz viele Leute grade einfach auch total verwirrt sind und sagen, ich blicke das nicht, jetzt gibt's die es es gibt ja die normale Corona-Warn etwas, was macht jetzt Luca anders und was macht jetzt dieses
geplante Update. Äh und ich glaube, deswegen ist es total gut, das nochmal aufzurollen, weil man kann nicht erwarten, dass alle so wie wir das irgendwie täglich.
Nachlesen und da auf dem Laufenden Stand sind. Und vielleicht fangen wir noch bei der bei der Corona-Warn-App an, also was die ja macht, ist ähm.
Versuchen, rauszubekommen, wie nah sich Menschen sind und das auf eine private freundliche Art.
Und ähm also allein dieses wie nah sind sich Menschen ist gar nicht so einfach zu machen, also diese ähm Bluetooth Low Energy ähm Technologie misst.
Signalstärke zwischen zwei Smartphones.
Und die Signalstärke wird unter anderem durch den Abstand beeinflusst, aber eben noch doch durch andere Sachen, also durch Hindernisse zum Beispiel Menschenkörper zwischen zwei Smartphones zum Beispiel ähm,
machen das Signal schon deutlich schwächer. Also es gab so es gab, als ich in den USA war ich mitbekommen gab's so Versuche zwei Menschen sitzen auf der Parkbank nebeneinander ähm und haben auf der jeweils entgegengesetzten der jeweils entgegengesetzten Hosentasche ihre Handys, dann sind zwei Menschenkörper dazwischen,
Damit war das Signal schon so schwach, als wenn sie sich auf einem Sportplatz fünfzig Meter voneinander entfernt aufhalten, aber quasi nur Luft,
Smartphones ist und das finde ich das das zeigt eigentlich ganz gut ähm auch die Schwäche natürlich von dieser Technologie, also die.
Das ist nur sehr ungefähr und geht natürlich, also muss, damit es funktioniert, viele sogenannte kreieren und darauf haben Forscher auch schon früh hingewiesen.
Wirklich wichtig ist zu verstehen, weil wenn.
Jetzt daraus schließt, okay, wenn dir diesen Sportplatzfall, wenn das eine Begegnung ist für diese für diese Technologie, wenn zwei Menschen fünfzig Meter entfernt sind, was ja aus äh epidemologischer Sicht natürlich überhaupt gar kein Problem ist.
Keine Begegnung wäre für die Corona-Warn-App, dann wäre eben auch das wir sitzen auf einer Parkbahn, nebeneinander keinen, wird's überhaupt nicht mehr funktionieren.
Das ist der Grund, warum alle Menschen sehr viel mehr äh diese rote Warnungen haben in der App, als tatsächlich sich dann auch angesteckt haben.
Und das ist richtig und wichtig so und deswegen wurde von Anfang an gesagt, das macht nur Sinn, diese Corona-Warnapp auf dieser Basis zu machen, wenn's auch genug Tests gibt, dass die Menschen dann sich zügig testen lassen können, dass man weiß, wer real infiziert ist.
Dazu kommt ja, dass auch gar nicht alle Menschen infektiös sind.
Das ist natürlich das Nächste. Also die Corona-Warn-App kann deswegen auch überhaupt keine Infektion messen, weil viele Menschen, die infiziert sind, ja gar niemanden anstecken. Das ist.
Das ist diese Besonderheit ähm die ja auch zu der Clusterbildung führt, ne, dass ein, also wenige Menschen stecken viele an und viele Menschen stecken gar niemanden an.
Der K-Wert.
Genau deswegen ist das Clustertracing auch ein Punkt. Linus, jetzt darfst du mich mal ergänzen.
Ja, also ich will.
So Corona war ein Apps sagen.
Es ist ja schön gesagt, also der äh was wir ja eigentlich versuchen mit diesen Messinstrumenten ist das Infektionsgeschehen irgendwie abzubilden und zu erfassen und ähm.
Bei der Corona-Warnapp funktioniert es eben über die Sendestärke von Bluetooth, ne? Und das also unsere Operationalisierung fürn Infektionsgefährden der Nähe zwischen Menschen ist dann hier eben ein
Funksignal gewisser Stärke wird über einen Zeitraum gewisser Länge empfangen und wenn das so ist, dann haben wir ein äh schicken wir nachher eine Warnung. Und das kann man vielleicht auch noch ganz kurz sagen
nochmal in Erinnerung rufen, die Handys schicken, eigentlich regelmäßig neue.
Zufällige Codes aus und im Falle einer Infektion werden also dann diese Codes veröffentlicht. Ja und das Schöne ist, da man veröffentlicht sie also zentral.
Das Wissen über die Codes, die quasi gefährlich waren, ja und die Leute, die die aber nicht empfangen haben, für die ist diese Information wertlos, ne? Und die eigentliche Datensammlung, wer welche Codes gehört hat, findet auf den.
Eigenen Geräten statt. Und das ist ja das, was du gerade mit dezentral eben so schön benannt hast und was sich hier so eine wunderschöne äh Beschreibung dafür finde, von einer der,
ähm der Erfinderin dieses Protokolls, wie es dann nachher umgesetzt wurde, äh Carmela Tromkose, mit der du ja auch gesprochen hast, äh die sagte so, diese Technologie ist so spezifisch für dieses Problem,
dass sie, wenn das Problem weg ist, keine andere Anwendung mehr hat. Ja, und das finde ich,
das schließt ja genau an diesen Aspekt an, den du jetzt auch mit der äh schon aus den MIT-Diskussionen beschrieben hast, dass es sich natürlich darüber Gedanken gemacht wurde, okay, wie können wir spezifisch dieses Problem lösen? Und wie können wir möglichst,
ähm keine Überwachungstechnologie bauen, weil.
Bei der stehen die Leute ja dann Schlange und erfinden die direkt den nächsten praktischen Anwendungsfall und dann werden wir sie nicht mehr los und das fand ich in dieser Debatte und es zieht sich ja bis heute durch, das ist das,
finde ich in der Diskussion so spannende ähm du hast einen einen Teil der Gesellschaft, die sind sehr,
bereit alle möglichen Rechte, Grundrechte, Sicherheitsrechte und so weiter über Bord zu werfen, in Anbetracht der Pandemie, ja, sagen also,
der Datenschutz muss sich jetzt hinten anstellen und so weiter. Und die sind auch bereit, das zu tun, unabhängig davon, ob das grade notwendig ist oder nicht, ja. Und das war ja so ein bisschen der Teil, in dem wir uns auch damals äh vor einem Jahr ungefähr
Chaos, Computerclub befunden haben, dass sie nämlich auch gesagt haben, okay, wenn wir jetzt hier,
ne, agieren wollt, im Rahmen dieser gesellschaftlichen Auseinandersetzung, da müssen wir sehr genau darauf aufpassen, dass sinnvolle Dinge getan werden, weil die Leute sind gerade auch bereit, unsinnige Dinge zu tun,
ne, das ich könnte jetzt sogar für mich persönlich sagen, ja, wäre es zur Bekämpfung der Pandemie.
Notwendig, Datenschutz zu lockern, wäre ich persönlich, also ich individuell, als Sinus Neumann wahrscheinlich sogar dazu bereit. Aber.
Jetzt kommt das wichtige Punkt. Ich müsste auch absolut erklärt bekommen haben, dass das notwendig ist, ja? Und dass das zielführend ist.
Ja und das ist hinterher wieder aufhören, ne. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiges Argument, was ganz viele Leute.
Unterschätzen, also das, dass es Kräfte gibt, die wirklich auf Überwachung stehen, nämlich unter anderem die Geheimdienste und äh dass die jede jede Gelegenheit nutzen, Daten zu sammeln in deren Denken,
ist Daten sammelt immer gut, weil man wer weiß, was man später darin noch finden kann.
Und die sorgen natürlich dafür, dass sowas auch dann bleibt. Also deswegen ist es nicht so einfach zu sagen, wir können's doch jetzt mal kurz aussetzen.
Ist jetzt ja nur für die Pandemie, weil in die Erfahrung zeigt, solche Technologien,
und solche Überwachungsmaßnahmen bleiben uns erhalten, weil es gibt dann hinterher für diese Kräfte kein gut genuges Argument zu sagen, jetzt kommt's aber wieder weg, weil dann kommt natürlich immer, ja, wir haben da nichts zu verbergen und rechtschaffende Menschen haben doch kein Problem damit und so weiter. Und ich glaube, das.
Was man sehen muss, dass die dass die Entscheidung ist größer als zu sagen, wir brauchen das jetzt nur für die Pandemie und das ist gefährlich.
Ne? Und trotzdem werde ich, ich ich sag's nur nochmal, ich, also weil ich das immer auch so provokativ sagen möchte,
wird's machen, wenn ich davon über, wenn man mir erklären würde, warum man das braucht. Ja, also eine nicht zielführende Maßnahme oder eine nicht notwendige Maßnahme äh ist
ist einfach immer grundsätzlich unsinnig, ne? Sie ist nicht, also sie ist unter anderem unsinnig, weil man da attraktive Datenberge wirft äh äh zusammen wirft. Sie ist aber auch ineffizient, ne? Man also in der
ziehen in der medizinischen Behandlung nimmt man ja auch immer nur so viel
Invasion oder so viel Invasivität, wie notwendig ist, ne? Also man behandelt,
die Krankheit und vielleicht würde bei jeder Erkältung Penizin helfen
ja? Man macht's aber nicht, weil man weiß, das kriegt man auch, was ne, mit einer Wärmflasche wieder in Griff. Und äh die hat wiederum viel geringere Nebenwirkungen. Das heißt, man sucht sich eine
zielgerichtete symptometierte Behandlung und hm man nimmt beleuchtet sich nicht
von innen mit UV-Licht und Trinkbleiche, weil das auch helfen könnte, sondern
man nimmt die, ne, man nimmt die Behandlung, die zielführend ist und minimalinvasiv. Den Begriff kenne ich daher.
Von meiner Knie-OP, ne, ja. Da wurde auch gesagt, okay, wir müssen dieses, wir müssen in diesem Knie innen drin äh operieren
ja? Und die die Unverletzlichkeit der Haut um das Knie herum, die ist uns jetzt mal zwischenzeitlich egal. Die werden wir jetzt opfern. Ja, wir werden da jetzt in diese Haut reinschneiden,
aber wir legen nicht das komplette Knie frei, sondern wir wir setzen sehr gezielte äh Schnitte für einen Periskop
und äh den ganzen Kladderadatsch. Und zwar genau das, was notwendig ist und nicht mehr, ja, während ich mit dem Knie da saß und und potenziell als jemand auch hätte sagen können, die Haut um mein Knie ist mir völlig egal.
Hauptsache innen drin wieder ganz.
Hauptsache innendrin wieder ganz, aber ne, das das illustriert vielleicht so ein bisschen, dass man trotzdem immer nicht, also gerade nicht sagt, viel hilft viel, sondern klug hilft viel,
und ähm das ist das war so ein bisschen die die gesellschaftliche Gefahr, die man hier gesehen hat. Ergänzend würde ich dazu sagen, ich weiß nicht, Tim, ob ich da jetzt vor vorweggreife, aber es gab ja dann auch in der Gastronomie diese,
die von dir auch angesprochene.
Erfassung von Adressen und er hat sich ja innerhalb von Wochen äh genau der Aspekt bestätigt, den Eva gerade schon nannte, denn es gab ja dann mehrere Bundesländern, in denen sofort die Polizei in in irgendwelche Kneipen gegangen ist und gesagt hat, hier,
zeigt mal Gästeliste wir glauben hier waren Drogendealer ja? Und das.
Ist ja dieser alte Satz, der wenn ich mich nicht täusche, dem äh Bundesverfassungsrichter Pap hier zugeordnet wird, ähm wo ein Druck ist, da sammeln sich die Schweine.
Genau, dann kommen wir vielleicht so auf das andere Problem, was wir jetzt erstmal äh schildern müssen, nämlich eben diese Situation von,
die in irgendeiner Form von dieser Pandemie äh betroffen sind. Das sind ja eine ganze Menge. Das Restaurant ist immer so ein bisschen das.
Kanonische Beispiels, gilt natürlich auch für viele andere, aber genau dort äh haben wir das ja auch alle erlebt, dass man dort eben
wenn man denn sozusagen schon da ist, zumindest seine Information hinterlässt, dass man auch da war von dann bis dann und dann eben eine Information hinterlegen muss
der man dann theoretisch später vom Gesundheitsamt,
erreicht werden kann und das war dann eben Teil dieser Infektionsschutzverordnung. Das hat dann eine ganze Menge Zettelwirtschaft ausgelöst,
auch seine Vorteile würde ich sagen, ne? Weil klar, die Daten werden da zwar alle erfasst.
Wenn sie jetzt überhaupt erstmal richtig waren, das haben wir noch eine andere Frage.
Aber sie sind nicht digital vor Ort, sie sind nicht zentral gespeichert, also von daher nicht so ohne weiteres in irgendjemandes Zugriff, auch wenn natürlich Missbrauch dort auch stattfinden kann, auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise, so Stichwort irgendwie
ne? Frauen, die sich in Restaurants aufhalten und dann von irgendwelchen äh vorlauten Personal kontaktiert werden. Ähm
Das sind aber so, sagen wir mal eher Nebenkriegsschaupätze. Äh die Daten können dann auch ganz gut,
vernichtet werden, weil man die Zettel halt einfach nach zwei Wochen wieder wegschmeißen kann. Nichtsdestotrotz war das irgendwie den Leuten auch so ein bisschen so ein Dorn in Auge und
Es wurde nach digitalen Lösungen geschrien. Und derer gab's ja dann auch so einige. Also dieses ganze
erfassungsdingen mit Computern und Telefonen. Das ging ja dann relativ schnell los. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass es also nicht lange gedauert hat und bei irgendwelchen äh Burgerläden hattest du dann so, ja, tipp doch hier einfach deine Kontaktdaten ein.
Dann haben wir, dann sind wir sozusagen hier unserer Berichtspflicht nachgekommen, aber wir haben jetzt keinen Bock hier irgendwie, euch viel Zeit zu klauen oder Großzettelwirtschaft zu machen
Das hatten wir ja dann auch schon mehrfach in der Sendung. Dann landeten die Daten halt,
unverschlüsselt auf irgendwelchen Servern, wo sie dann relativ problemlos wieder herausgepopelt werden konnten und man schön irgendwie umfangreiche Listen über sehr viele Leute, über sehr viele Orte, über sehr lange Zeiträume hinweg
nachforschen konnte und das war natürlich ähm jetzt auch nicht unbedingt im Sinne des Erfinders. Ähm seit wann gibt's denn.
Sinnvolle Lösung eigentlich dafür. Was haben wir denn?
Wann gab's denn irgendwie die ersten wirklichen Bewegungen von Leuten, die gesagt haben, okay, also wenn schon, äh digital dann anders.
Also ich glaube, das ging schon relativ äh früh los, dass es zum Beispiel auch in irgendeiner Weise verschlüsselte Lösungen gab, ne, für dieses.
Für diese Adresserfassung in der Gastronomie, wo wo irgendwie versucht wurde, das Risiko, also einerseits zentral zu sammeln, ja, aber irgendwie die Verschlüsselung dann zum Beispiel an den.
An die Gastwirtin selber oder an den gastronomischen Betrieb irgendwie vorzunehmen ähm in einem Versuch, weniger ähm.
Ja, weniger Datenleckrisiko an zentraler Stelle zu haben. Das gab's auch schon, also das war, glaube ich, das letzte Ding, was die
Leute aufgemacht haben, habe ich irgendwann letztes Jahr noch mit denen die PM zugeschrieben. Da gab's dann ähm ja ein geringeres Risiko
kleinere Mengen Daten rauszutragen, aber nicht mit einem Hack alle, ja? Ähm,
und diese Idee ist jetzt nicht sonderlich neu, würde ich sagen. Einen Durchbruch hatte sie in meinen Augen im,
das muss ungefähr im Oktober gewesen sein, als ähm.
Das Team eben um Camilla Tronkoso ähm,
Wauterlux, dieses Team, die auch schon an der ähm an dem,
oh jetzt DP3T, ne? Oder ist das PT, drei DT, ich äh privat.
Also die drei TP, also ich verwechsel's ja auch immer. Ja, vielleicht auch nicht.
Servin. Ich glaube drei P.
Die Petra T.
DP3T.
DP3T, okay. Die Central Life Privacy, okay. DP3T ähm.
Dem letztendlich dem, was Apple und Google dann gebaut haben, ja? Und die haben sich ja dann äh zusammengesetzt und haben gesagt, okay, wenn man nun.
Ein System bauen möchte, das Zusammenkünfte erkennt, wo als wir sagen jetzt nicht mehr, wir merken uns Individuen, sondern wir merken uns eine Zusammenkunft. Dann kann man das sehr, sehr ähnlich wie in der, in dem,
Corona-Warn-Air-Protokoll eben auch machen, indem sich die Gruppe, die sich trifft, im Prinzip.
Ein Geheimnis gibt und wenn dieses Geheimnis dann auf dem gleichen Weg oder auf einer ähnlichen Wege veröffentlicht wird, weiß alles klar, jetzt war diese Zusammenkunft ist jetzt gerade alarmiert worden und das könnte ähm,
eben interessant sein für Menschen, die ähm vielleicht dieses äh Bluetooth äh System nicht nutzen können oder nicht
nutzen möchten, weil sie Angst vor Strahlungen haben oder ne, was auch immer es für Gründe gibt. Und ich denke auch, es war ein bisschen motiviert durch diese wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis, dass es eben,
Cluster gibt und ähm nicht unbedingt die,
Weiter Infektion linear von einer Person an. Eine geht, sondern eben von vielen Personen erstmal an niemanden und dafür in einigen,
wenigeren Gruppen von einer Person an mehrere. Das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der der Prozess, der da von der, sagen wir mal, von der.
Technischen Lösung her würde ich sagen, hat er da seinen Höhepunkt erreicht als dieses Protokoll ähm,
irgendwann im Oktober spezifiziert wurde. Ich weiß, dass deshalb, weil ich tatsächlich eine sehr rudimentäre Idee davon damals in einem Blogpost geschrieben habe und einen Tag später.
Das fertige Paper,
von äh eine seriöses so rauskam, wo sie es mal, ne, wo ich so dachte, ja so ungefähr könnte man das machen und die hatten aber dann auf, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Seiten das vollständig ausspezifiziert, tausendmal,
genauer, ne und Kryptographisch spezifiziert und was nicht alles, was sich nur als als blöden, als als grobe Konzeptidee mal hatte. Und das war irgendwann im Oktober letzten Jahr, Anfang Oktober zwanzig zwanzig.
Das Spannende daran finde ich ähm tatsächlich, dass dieses Clusterthema ja auch schon lange diskutiert wird, irgendwie leider viel zu wenig hierzulande. Ich da habe ich mal drüber recherchiert.
In Japan ist das ein zentraler Ansatz, der wohl auch sehr gut funktioniert, dass diese sogenannte.
Also die Idee oder weil man weiß, dass die meisten Menschen ja niemanden anstecken.
Sind ja auch die meisten Menschen eigentlich völlig ähm sinnloserweise in Quarantäne. Man weiß aber nur nicht welche das sind, ne? Also man weiß nicht, welche sinnvoller Weise in Quarantäne sind, weil man eben nicht weiß, wer diese zwanzig oder zehn Prozent sind,
Zahlen schwanken das so ein bisschen die Angaben der der Wissenschaftlerinnen ähm ob das die sind, die infektiös sind, aber tatsächlich ist das ja so, dass die meisten Menschen niemanden anstecken.
Und wenn man das besser einschätzen könnte, könnte man natürlich viel zielgerichterter und auch viel schneller die Richtigen in Quarantäne stecken und vor allem auch den richtigen ähm.
Infektionswegen folgen, also was die in Japan machen, ist oder was wir machen ist ja oder unsere Gesundheitsämter. Äh wer infiziert ist, äh kommt in Quarantäne und alle ersten also alle nahen Kontaktpersonen kommen ebenfalls in Quarantäne.
Die in Japan machen, was ist man guckt von wem wurden denn die infiziert.
Dann hat man jemand, der sicher, also da hat man jemand aus dieser zwanzig Prozent Gruppe oder zehn Prozentgruppe von Menschen, die infektiös sind, also dann weiß man, der,
hat auf jeden Fall andere infiziert und guckt dann von dem oder von derjenigen aus wieder nach vorne und guckt, wen hat denn der oder die getroffen und erwischt somit sehr viel höhere Wahrscheinlichkeiten, andere Menschen, die angesteckt worden sind.
Und letztlich ist es einfach 'ne sehr viel effizientere Art Contect Racing zu betreiben.
Und das geht natürlich auch auf der Basis von so wie wie bisher eben gemacht wird, also quasi manuell, der contect racer vom Gesundheitsamt äh trifft sich mit der infizierten und bespricht mit ihr, wen hast du in Eis in letzter Zeit getroffen und dann werden diese Leute benachrichtigt, das könnte man genauso als,
sogenannte machen und.
Das ist aber eine Idee, auf der ihr mir jetzt dieses dieses Protokoll ähm beruht, was du Linus gerade beschrieben hast, dass man das natürlich auch technisch unterstützen kann, indem man nämlich.
Durch diese Art, ähm das das ähm der Kontakt nachverfolgen, rausbekommt, wo wo hat sich ein Cluster gebildet, weil mit der normalen klassischen Corona-Warn-App.
Den Ortsbezug nicht, ne, also selbst die Leute, die die informiert werden von der App, du hast einen gefährlichen Kontakt, wissen ja nicht.
Stattgefunden hat, das weiß gar niemand und das ist auch gut so. Und mit diesem ähm mit diesem äh dem Ansatz könnte man eben durch die Cluster.
Schneller finden und das fand ich ja, wie du auch beschrieben hast.
Total clever und und gut zu sehen, dass auch dafür freundliche Lösung gibt.
Dass auch dafür ähm also erstmal auch da die die Daten dezentral und und sehr sicher äh lagern und verarbeiten kann.
Der
der Spaß dabei ist ja kommt eben ohne die Ortsinformation aus, ne? Man sagt nämlich, also man spezifiziert die Zusammenkunft und es ist im Prinzip so gemacht, dass äh da als Beispiel jetzt eine investigative Journalistin kann sich mit drei Quellen konspirativ treffen, das Ding
in registrieren, ja und äh wird ähm hat muss keine Sorge haben, dass eine zentrale Datenbank
jemals erfährt, dass sie dieses ähm Treffen hatten. Ne, man könnte das nur herausfinden, wenn man jetzt alle drei Handys hätte und würde schauen und würde sagen, ah okay, passt mal auf, ihr habt euch, ihr habt euch, hier zumindest einmal in dieser.
Zusammenkunft getroffen, aber da die Handys diese diese Daten nicht rausgeben, an irgendeine zentrale Stelle, ist es eben sehr ähm sauber zu lösen. Ich würde an dieser Stelle noch einen wichtigen Punkt sagen, den wir, glaube ich, in der Diskussion über contact tracing
nie vergessen dürfen, ähm zu erwähnen, weil es natürlich auch, das haben wir bei der Corona-Warn-App gesehen, das sehen wir jetzt auch in der Debatte um Luca
ganz, ganz unrealistische Heilsversprechen gibt, die Leute diesen Apps zumessen,
und hm bei der Corona-Warne war das irgendwie tatsächlich so, dass die Leute denken, dass sie jetzt wegen dieser App kein Corona kriegen
und bei der Luka-App ist es so, dass die Leute denken, dass deswegen die Gastronomie wieder aufmachen kann, während die Inzidenz irgendwo wunderbar bei hundertvierzig oder was jetzt liegt, ne und das.
All das nein, nein, nein, nein. Das Einzige, was contact racing im Kampf gegen die Pandemie tun kann, ist.
Infiziert potenziell infizierte Menschen warnen, die dann aber schon entweder infiziert sind oder nicht, ne, daran kann sich nichts ändern,
nur wenn diese potenziell infizierten Personen dann ihre Kontakte reduzieren und sagen, okay, oh, Warnung in der App, ich sage mal, die Chorprobe heute Abend ab,
ja? Und statt zur Korprobe gehe ich zum Test. Und wenn ich den Test äh negativ habe, ist alles gut und wenn ich den Test positiv habe, habe ich gerade potenziell, ne, vielleicht meine.
Chor gerettet.
Meinen Chor gerettet, ja? Oder der wäre dann irgendwie signifikant dezimiert worden, wenn ich dort hingegangen wäre, ne? So
vielleicht nur ich. Also, das ist und das ist der einzige Effekt, ja, diese Apps können immer nur und das ist, glaube ich, auch oder kann immer nur diejenigen Menschen retten,
die es vielleicht nie erfahren.
Ja, weil weil vielleicht die infizierte Person ihrem Chor sagt, och du, ich habe Kopfschmerzen. Und nicht, ich habe äh Corona, ne? Oder ich komme heute mal nicht oder vielleicht muss man sich beim Chor auch gar nicht entschuldigen, wenn man nicht kommt, ne? Und das heißt,
Der Effekt.
Hilft immer nur den Leuten, die es vielleicht gar nicht erfahren. Und deswegen fehlen die Geschichten von Leuten, die sagen, ey geil, weil ich die Corona-Warn-App habe, habe ich,
eine Risikosituation vermieden. Es gibt nur die Menschen, die sagen, weil ich die Corona-Warn-App habe.
Ähm habe ich mich testen lassen und war positiv. Die App hat funktioniert oder die Menschen, die sagen, äh weil ich die Corona war, nicht habe, hatte ich eine Warnung, aber die war gar nicht echt scheiß App. Ich habe gar kein Corona, ja. Statt sich ähm.
Eben zu freuen. Und dieser, dieser Effekt ist, dass das, denke ich, muss man auch in jeder Debatte nochmal anbringen. Ähm.
Wenn man jetzt mal zugrunde legen würde.
Für die Mathematik am einfachsten, die Hälfte der Menschheit, äh die Hälfte eines der Bevölkerung diese App nutzt und die andere Hälfte nicht,
ja, dann heißt es natürlich auch, dass nur die Hälfte der Leute äh Kontakte registrieren und zwar auch nur mit der.
Hälfte der Leute, die sie treffen, ne, also fünfzig Prozent nutzen die App, dann wäre das jetzt hier in in einer Zusammenkunft von vier Personen wären es zwei, die äh sich dann eben nachher warnen können und zwei, die nicht gewarnt werden. Das heißt.
Ende erreichst du bei fünfzig Prozent App-Nutzung nur ein Viertel,
der Kontakte, ne, weil nur die Hälfte der Leute ähm die App haben und von den Leuten, die die treffen, auch wieder nur die Hälfte. Jetzt verteilt sich natürlich ein bisschen ungleichmäßig und so, aber letztendlich brauchst du enorme Nutzungszahlen.
Damit das äh überhaupt ein äh sinnvollen Effekt haben kann. Und das brauchst du natürlich auch ähm.
Bei einer,
App, die jetzt irgendwie so ist, denn irgendwann einmal so wäre, in der äh Gastronomie die Daten erfasst. Und da, glaube ich, gehen ganz, ganz unrealistische Heilsversprechen
immer mit einher und ich hatte ja schon vor einiger Zeit hier in der Sendung gesagt, ich freue mich schon so in ein paar Monaten
wenn die Leute sehen, dass äh Luca ihn auch nicht den Allerwertesten gerettet hat, dann kann der gute Smudo sich aber echt warm anziehen, weil so wie er jetzt halt monatelang dafür getrommelt hat, äh kommt er aus der Nummer auch nicht mehr raus.
Und das ist, finde ich, eine riesen Verantwortung, die er hat und also so sehr, also ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mich dann freuen wollen würde, aber ähm.
Das Tragische ist ja, dass grade wahnsinnig viel Geld auch für die App ausgegeben wird. Also speziell für die Luca-App, weil.
So sehr die Hoffnung schürt. Also er hat mehrmals wirklich ziemlich direkt gesagt.
Die holt uns aus dem Lockdown raus, das ist Teil einer Öffnungsstrategie, die rettet die Kulturwirtschaft und und auch die ganzen armen Restaurants ähm.
Und das, finde ich, ist eine riesen Verantwortung. Jetzt wird eben, also sie sind bis jetzt bekannt ist, sind die Kosten von sechs Bundesländern, sind zehn Komma fünf Millionen Euro.
Ich glaube, zwölf Bundesländer haben jetzt schon feste Verträge.
Das heißt, wenn man's doppelt, sind wahrscheinlich ausgegeben schon eher drei Millionen Euro und also wenn das bundesweit eingeführt wird, dann sind wir.
So war mal, meine Kalkulation sind wir nach zwei Jahren bei dem bei dem Geld, was die Corona-Warn-App gekostet hat.
Und seine seine Freunde von Luca sagen immer noch, sie wären günstig und schimpfen auf die unglaublich teure Corona-Warn-App oder andere, wie du ja gesagt hast, schimpfen auf die Corona-Warn-App, die teuer war, auch nicht mal funktionieren würde, was natürlich Quatsch ist. Also die funktioniert.
Ziemlich gut. Also ich kenne dich nur anekdotisch viele Geschichten von von Leuten aus dem Freundeskreis, die die nur auf die Art von ihrer äh von ihrer ähm Infektion erfahren haben, die nie vom Gesundheitsamt kontaktiert wurden.
Und es gibt ja auch die Zahlen, wie viele Menschen, obwohl es freiwillig ist, ihr positives Testergebnis teilen. Ich glaube, das waren das siebzig Prozent oder fünfundsiebzig. Also jedenfalls.
'ne große Mehrheit aller Menschen, die die App haben und positiv getestet werden, teilen dieses Ergebnis, obwohl es freiwillig wird. Und all diese Argumente.
Umgedreht gerade, von von Smudo und von Luca nämlich Freiwilligkeit funktioniert nicht,
sieht man ja in der Corona-Wahn etwas nicht stimmt. Da sieht man nämlich, dass es funktioniert. Also Leute, haben die freiwillig Leute melden sich freiwillig Leute gehen freiwillig zum Test, wenn sie eine rote Warnung kriegen und so weiter.
Und ähm natürlich kann man, gibt's da keine Zahlen dazu, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die Gesundheitsämter mit ihrer direkten Nachfolge echt nur einen kleinen Bruchteil von den,
diesen Zahlen erreichen, die die dadurch natürlich ähm größer werden, ja? Also es wird mehr werden mehr, letztlich Ansteckungen verhindert auf dem Weg, weil mehr Leute davon erfahren, dass sie möglicherweise infiziert sind und sich testen lassen und anderen fern bleiben.
Entsprechende Studien gibt es ja aus ähm
Großbritannien, da ist die App ja nach äh anfänglich ähm ja dem falsch eingeschlagenen Weg ja auch nochmal komplett neu gemacht worden und setzt auf das selbe Framework auf, wie die Corona-Warn-App und dann ging das mit der Adoption ganz gut und es gibt Studien, die halt wirklich
nennenswerte ähm Zahlen von verhinderten Fällen da äh herausrechnen. Das
Ja, ich habe die Zahlen jetzt gerade auswendig nicht äh am Start, können die Linke ja nochmal in die machen, was ich aber eigentlich damit sagen will, ist, es gibt sozusagen schon ein Potential von verhinderten Ansteckungen und wenn man dann mal hochrechnet, was uns sozusagen eine Ansteckung in der Gesellschaft
kostet. Eine einzige Ansteckung, also eine Person, die entweder krank wird und dann im Krankenhaus.
Eine Behandlung braucht, mindestens ein paar Tage vielleicht im Krankenhaus liegt oder
schlimmsten Fall halt sogar einen schweren äh Verlauf hat, dann gehen die Kosten halt schnell in die Abertausende, aber auch eine Person, die einfach nur in Quarantäne ist und vierzehn Tage nicht arbeiten kann, ist ein Verlust für die Volkswirtschaft. Und wenn man diese Fälle mal multipliziert, dann kommt man eben schnell auf eine Ersparnis, die äh
weit über den Kosten liegt, die jetzt für die Corona-Warn-App ausgegeben wurde. Da ihr jetzt schon auf die Luka-App ähm,
angefangen habt, einzugehen mit so einer äh Bewertung, finde ich, sollten wir an dieser Stelle jetzt nochmal diese Kategorie von Apps.
Nochmal kurz würdigen und dann mal genau erklären, was versucht eigentlich diese Luca App und was ist
dann auch so der Grund, warum sie überhaupt so in diese Diskussion gekommen ist. Also die.
Ich hatte ja vorhin gesagt so, okay, es gibt so eine neue Kategorie von Apps. Jetzt sind wir schon so ein bisschen auf
Crowd Notiffeier und sozusagen die Ideen der äh ja security orientierten Gemeinschaft äh gekommen. Aber die ersten Ideen, die so App-Entwickler gehabt haben, war ja einfach aha, okay, die Corona-Schutzverordnung schreibt das und das vor.
Das ist mit Zettelwirtschaft äh zu erschlagen. Leute mögen das nicht oder finden das problematisch aus den erwähnten Gründen
na ja, dann machen wir das doch irgendwie mit Computer, machen wir das doch mit mit Smartphones. Das ist ja sozusagen immer so eine Reaktion und und das finde ich auch okay. Also man kann da ja drüber nachdenken
ja, man kann ja drüber nachdenken und dann muss man halt zum Schluss kommen das geht oder es geht nicht. So und dann gab's eben verschiedene Ansätze, die nicht so gut funktioniert haben, weil sie einfach zu tump waren.
Aber dann gab's da auch ein paar, die schon dann auch über das eigentliche Problem des Datenschutzes sich Gedanken gemacht haben und eben verschiedene Kaskaden von Verschlüsselung eingeführt haben.
Ähm jetzt müsst ihr immer mal sagen, gibt's denn außer der Luca App noch ein noch einen anderen Player, den man an der Stelle vielleicht nochmal erwähnen sollte, die die sich ähnlich dort in diesem Feld beschäftigt haben und unterwegs waren?
Ähm also Recover gibt's da glaube ich, die sind mir äh bekannt ähm vom Prinzip her nicht
wesentlich unterschiedlich und dann gibt es ja sogar, also muss ja wirklich sagen, dieses Feld. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte das nur eine äh eine Firma äh beacker,
ne? Es war nur um das nochmal in der Historie, in Erinnerung zu rufen, eigentlich all viele Gastronomiesysteme
Ja, die im Prinzip einfach die IT für deine Gastronomie anbieten, mit Kasse und haste nicht gesehen, ne? Haben solche Systeme gebaut, weil sie das, ja, mehr oder weniger als, als notwendigen Mehrwert für ihre Kundinnen und Kunden verstanden haben.
Ähm und die haben sich ja dann auch zusammengeschlossen in dieser Gruppierung
wir für Digitalisierung hieß das, oder? Wo sie quasi sich dagegen gewehrt haben zu sagen, Moment mal, wir, wir betreiben diesen Spaß hier auch schon etwas länger, ja? Wir haben auch technische Lösungen, die
ebenbürtig sind, ne? Wir haben uns auch auf einen von dem Gesetzgeber
bereitgestelltes Problem gestürzt. Und äh wir haben aber jetzt leider keinen Bekannten äh Rapper, der in der Lage ist, über Monate eine mediale Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren und deswegen wünschen wir uns jetzt aber bitte auch ähm,
ja äh zumindest Chancengleichheit.
Also das ist nicht so, als wäre das ein Feld, was nur einige wenige beackert haben. Viel mehr ist es so, dass also sämtliche Versuche unsererseits da mal einen vollständigen Überblick zu bekommen
ähm ja, völlig, völlig, völlig fehlgeschlagen sind.
Auf die Zahl gestoßen, es ist fünfzig ähnliche, also die werden ja check in Apps auch genannt manchmal oder Event Apps, also fünfzig ähnliche Startups in Deutschland gibt, die sich damit beschäftigt haben und ich glaube.
Niemand hat die ähm wirklich eingehend verglichen und ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass die alle fünfzig.
Sehr gute Verschlüsselung bieten, ähm aber zumindest, genau, also ist es falsch zu behaupten, es gibt es gibt nur die eine, auch wenn der der öffentliche Eindruck manchmal.
Entstehen könnte, dass es nur Luca gibt, das ist einfach nur die eine mit dem besten Marketing.
Wir kommen da noch drauf, dass das auch das ist, was sie wirklich am allerbesten können,
und das vieles andere dahinter im Argen liegt was die App gefragt was macht diese Apps eigentlich aus? Was ist das für eine eigene Klasse an Apps.
Unterschied eben zu so Ansätzen wie der Corona-Warn-App ist, dass dass du, das hatten wir auch schon so ein bisschen eingedeutet, dass du quasi damit selbst bestätigst. Ich bin jetzt hier in diesem Restaurant. Du kannst einchecken,
Du hast einen QR-Code und die ähm jeweiligen Orte, also Events, aber auch private Treffen können sich einen eigenen QR-Code generieren.
Dann kannst du dich einchecken und damit bestätigst du quasi ich bin jetzt hier und das ist natürlich was, was die Corona-Warn-App nicht kann. Das daher kommen ja die vielen auch,
dass eben dieses Bluetooth Proxity Tracing,
nicht nicht so genau ist, dass jeder Fall von, wir haben hier eine Nähe gemessen, auch eine reale Nähe ist, weil manchmal ist noch eine Wand dazwischen und dann, also das habe ich oft gehört, übrigens, dass die Nachbarn waren infiziert und dann ist bei den Leuten die App Knalle rot und hat zwanzig Risikobegegnungen.
Gezeigt, obwohl natürlich sich bei Nachbarn nicht ansteckt, solange die Wand zwischen einem ist, also wenn,
nicht im Treppenhaus, lange quatscht, checkt man sich bei denen ja auch nicht an. Und das ist was, ähm was diese Apps darüber hinaus ähm lösen, ne, dass sie es, dass dass das halt dadurch, dass derjenige bestätigt und der und das Event, der Ort des Restaurants bestätigt, der ist und die ist jetzt hier,
dass das schon mal diese Ungenauigkeit rausfällt, die waren dann wirklich da.
Aber da würde ich, da würde ich kurz ergänzen, also das ist ähm also du hast recht, es nimmt die,
Ungenauigkeit der Erfassung weg, ja, also die Corona-Warn-App,
erkennt nicht die Wand, ja, eine Check-In-App erkennt die Wand, die sich zwischen den Leuten ähm äh befindet, allerdings kommt das zu zwei Preisen.
Erstens, die Automatisierung ist weg, ja? Vor die Corona-Warn-App, mit der musst du dich nicht beschäftigen, mit diesen Check-In Apps musst du dich dauerhaft beschäftigen,
Und zweitens,
ist aber das, was sie erfasst insgesamt wieder ungenauer. Ja, weil also diese Restaurantsituation, die er jetzt hier immer wieder als Beispiel ähm.
Äh bereitgestellt wird, ne,
da ist es mir im Zweifelsfall relativ egal, in einem großen Restaurant, dass sich am anderen Ende des des Saales oder vielleicht sogar in einem zweiten Raum äh eine infizierte
Person äh befunden hat. Das heißt, das was sie erfassen, ist insgesamt das ungenauere Maß, aber das erfassen sie mit einer höheren,
Reliabilität. Solange du sie nutzt, nämlich sie die erfassen einfach gar nichts, wenn du es nicht eincheckst und einscannst.
Ja und was spannend ist da, wie du sagst, die äh die erfassen nur, du bist eben auch da gewesen, aber nichts weiter,
Gesundheitsämter jetzt schon sagen, also das habe ich von Leuten gehört, die Gesundheitsämter arbeiten, dass sie nicht sicher sind, ob sie mit diesen Daten wirklich was anfangen können, weil da kommt natürlich dann ein Datenwust.
Dabei zählen eben noch viele andere Faktoren, wenn dran. Da muss solche Daten irgendwie auch einschätzen können, wie weit saßen die auseinander? Wie sind die Gegebenheiten vor Ort überhaupt gewesen?
Dann kommt er dazu, dass darauf kommen wir vielleicht auch nachher noch, wenn wenn wir tief die Luca App an sich erklärt haben, ähm dass das mit dem ein und auschecken, mit dem automatischen, offenbar noch nicht so richtig gut funktioniert. Also das das hat sich jetzt gezeigt in verschiedenen Feldversuchen.
Und auch versuchen von von Leuten die auch mal getestet haben wie geht es so, dass eben manche Leute einfach noch.
Eingecheckt waren, obwohl sie schon weg waren von dem Ort. Also das das arbeitet ja auch mit mit Standort teilweise, mit ähm deiner Nähe zu diesem Ort. Das macht natürlich noch mehr ähm.
Rauschen in die Daten oder mach die noch unzuverlässiger. Das ist natürlich also die muss genau dazu recht, muss man einschränken, die Daten sind deswegen nicht genauer.
Und dann vielleicht noch nur um nochmal kurz den Unterschied zu zeigen, jetzt also wenn wir jetzt wieder zurück zu äh Luca gehen ähm.
Was Luca jetzt auch noch anders macht, ist, die Daten sollen wieder durch das Gesundheitsamt gehen, ja? Ähm.
Ähnlich wie es die Papierzettelchen ebenfalls tun würden, sofern das gesunde,
Gesundheitsamt sie abfragt. Was wir ja tatsächlich sehen, das hatte ich hier auch schon
erzählt. Das habe ich mir auch inzwischen von einer Freundin, die beim Gesundheitsamt arbeitet, bestätigen lassen, dass das Gesundheitsamt tatsächlich in der Regel nicht,
nach den Kontaktlisten der gastronomischen Einrichtung fragt, weil sie,
beim Kontect Tracing eben nach Risiko Kontakten suchen und das bedeutet eben eher, wenn man denen sagt, an dem und dem Tag war ich essen, ne, dass die dann eher sagen, okay, mit wem?
Statt äh wo. Das
scheint im Moment die Praxis der äh Gesundheitsämter zu sein. Das deckt sich damit, dass sich ja auch je schon mal erwähnt, Gastronominnen kenne
deren die Fälle hatten, die dann dem Gesundheitsamt die Daten geben wollten und das Gesundheitsamt hat nur abgewunken und hat gesagt, das sind einfach, ne, das ist die Arbeit machen wir uns nicht, weil
wenn wir jetzt hier deine Gäste alle alarmieren, die sind sowieso im Zweifelsfall nicht äh infiziert worden. Ähm so zum, also so zumindest die,
die gelebte Praxis äh bis irgendwann Oktober letzten Jahres, solange wir noch eine Gastronomie hatten.
Jetzt lass uns doch mal konkret mal darüber reden, was jetzt diese Luca-App exakt genau tut, soweit wir das,
wisst, weil ich glaube, äh vieles in dieser ganzen Debatte auch das Problem
Luca App, aber keiner weiß eigentlich, worüber wir eigentlich genau reden. Und bevor wir jetzt hier weiter so blumig bleiben, äh sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz beschreiben, was soll.
Was was tut die App konkret? Gehen wir's doch einfach mal durch so. Ich
lade mir jetzt diese App irgendwie runter, weil mir gesagt wurde, das wäre jetzt irgendwie der geile, neue Scheiß und der eröffnet mir das Paradies eines äh öffentlichen, kulturellen Lebens.
Hat mein Oberbürgermeister gesagt und viel Geld ausgegeben. Ich lade also jetzt diese App runter, starte die. Was passiert dann?
Musst du dich anmelden und dabei wird als einziges überprüft die Telefonnummer, also auch hier kannst du dich mit falschem Namen anmelden, weil das ja letztlich so ein bisschen egal ist.
Aber deine Telefonnummer wird verifiziert, indem du eine SMS, so wie bei vielen anderen ja Apps Apps ja auch in der SMS bekommst und mit einer Tannen und die dann eingibst.
Da gibt's auch Schwachstellen, wurde schon gezeigt, aber im Prinzip ist das die Idee.
Dass du in der Regel damit deine Telefonnummer verifiziert hast und das Gesundheitsamt später auch eine reale Telefonnummer von einem echten Menschen und auch von demjenigen hat, der die App hat, mit dem sie dich auf unter der sie dich anrufen können.
Okay, okay und dann gebe ich nur noch meinen Namen an und sonst gar nichts.
Ich glaube, du kannst auch die E-Mail-Adresse angeben. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ähm das Wichtige ist, dass die Telefonnummer der Rest ist ja ein bisschen egal, wenn der nicht verifiziert wird, ne, was du angibst. Wichtig ist,
Für die Argumentation ist wichtig, dass die Telefonnummer stimmt, für die Argumentation oder für der äh Befürworter. Ist das relevant?
Ne, weil bisher in äh Restaurants natürlich äh Menschen auch falsche Telefonnummern angegeben haben, neben falschen Namen und dann kann man mit den Daten,
davon ausgehe, dass die genutzt werden sollen vom Gesundheitsamt natürlich nicht viel anfangen.
Jetzt würde ich schon noch ganz gerne, du hast gerade gesagt, äh da gibt's auch Schwachstellen. Ähm das hatten wir im Logbuch auch schon besprochen in einer frühen Folge, aber das ist genau also was Eva gerade sagt, ist
wenn man da also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich da auch einen Namen eingeben musste. Mit der Adresse weiß ich jetzt tatsächlich nicht mehr, weil ich's bei mir jetzt auch schon einige Zeit wieder her, dass ich diese App ausprobiert habe. Ähm
da gab es diesen wunderschönen Fehler, dass sie ähm einem zwar einen per SMS einen Code zusenden
aber quasi die Prüfung, ob
Code stimmt, findet nicht serverseitig statt. Das heißt, man kann sich also spätestens im, wenn man's über den Webbrowser macht, ganz einfach dort registrieren und sagen, yo, yo, ich habe den richtigen Code bekommen und eingegeben und kann
dann am Ende diese Luca-App auf äh jede mögliche Telefonnummer registrieren. Also,
das das eine Ding, was sie da richtig machen sollten, haben sie dann nicht richtig gemacht, dann haben sie wieder gesagt, das muss aber so, dass dass wir, das haben wir extra falsch gemacht. Ähm nein
ein ewiges Hin und Her. Ich habe hier gerade mal so eine Werbe äh Broschüre von Luca ähm.
Vor mir. Da steht auch noch drauf, zweifache Verschlüsselung der Kontaktdaten.
Ja und das ist tatsächlich interessant, weil ganz lange haben die auch gesagt, wieso, wir haben doch eine dezentrale App und wir haben immer gefragt, wenn ich mich auch gefragt, aber wenn die Daten doch zentral bei Luca aufm Server gespeichert werden.
Wie ist es dezentral gemeint? Und das haben sie mit dieser Verschlüsselung gemeint, weil die Schlüssel, weil man zwei Schlüssel braucht, um an die Daten ranzukommen und die liegen bei verschiedenen.
Institutionen. Und dadurch behaupten sie, und das fand ich echt schon bisschen dreist. Wir haben doch eine dezentrale Lösung, aber die ist nur virtuell dezentralisiert, nämlich über diese Schlüssel.
Der eine ist der vom Gesundheitsamt, die Gesundheitsamt bekommen einen Schlüssel, auch da gab's und da gibt's immer noch.
Unklarheiten, weil wohl eine ganze Zeit lang oder auch noch immer das einfach ein einziger gleicher Schlüssel war für alle Gesundheitsämter.
Und ähm die Restaurants haben einen. Und das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand.
Also du, Tim, hast die App runtergeladen, gehst ins Restaurant, äh wirst zwei Tage später krank, lässt dich testen.
Dann sagt das Gesundheitsamt der contectracer, okay, wo warst denn du und dann kannst du sagen, ja hier, ich kann mit kann euch gerne mein.
Dein Tagebuch mit der von der oder meine Kontakthistorie oder meine Historie von Restaurants, von von Orts und von Events ähm geben.
Das heißt, der Nutzer gibt dann das dem Gesundheitsamt frei. Damit gehen dann die, geht es Gesundheitsamt zu dem Restaurant und sagt hier äh.
Wir brauchen quasi die Liste von Leuten, die zur gleichen Art äh zur gleichen Zeit auch an diesem Ort hier waren. Und um diese Liste an die zu kommen, braucht man den Schlüssel vom Gesundheitsamt und dem von dem Restaurant. Das ist diese doppelte Verschlüsselung.
Damit angeblich die Daten dezentralisiert, was natürlich nicht stimmt.
Also nur um nochmal, wie die wie das quasi als Verschlüsselungspaket aussieht, du hast dein Handy, hat deine Gesundheitsdaten, äh dein hey, sorry, deine Kontaktdaten, verschlüsselt die an das Gesundheitsamt,
und dieses an das Gesundheitsamt verschlüsselte Päckchen wird nochmal an die Betreiberin verschlüsselt. Und so wird eben sichergestellt, dass das
Gesundheitsamt nur darauf zugreifen kann, wenn die Betreiberin diese Daten dem Gesundheitsamt.
Tief bereitstellt. Ne, also weder die Betreiberin hat die Daten und kann drankommen, noch,
das Gesundheitsamt und so sagen dann eben auch die Luca Leute, sie können auch nicht drankommen, weil diese Daten ja
zunächst einmal an die Betreiberin und dann auch nochmal an das Gesundheitsamt verschlüsselt sind. Jetzt würde ich aus technischer Perspektive nur noch mal etwas dazu sagen. Äh der.
Der Betreiberinnen teil, der der das nennt sich Luca Locations, also sie haben die Luca-App. Sie haben Luca Locations, das ist für die Betreiberin von Einrichtungen und sie haben Luca Gesundheitsamt, ja, das ist quasi dann,
das Interface, von dem aus die Gesundheitsämter sich die Daten ähm aufbereiten lassen können.
Wenn du so etwas baust, hast du immer das Problem, dass.
Ja, letztendlich Luka entscheidet, welche Schlüssel du verwendest für das Gesundheitsamt und welche Schlüssel du verwendest für ähm die Location. Und Duck.
Könnten, können äh Fehler bei Passieren. Ähm üblicherweise haben schwächt man diese Systeme ähm.
Leider aus aus einem bestimmten Grund. Und dieser Grund ist nämlich, dass man.
Dass man jetzt eine Situation hat, in der diese Leute die Luca Locations nutzen, ein Schlüsselpaar,
in ihren Händen halten, dass wenn sie das verlieren, ihnen sehr große Schwierigkeiten macht, nämlich sie könnten potenziell ihrer ähm.
Pflicht nicht mehr nachkommen, dem Gesundheitsamt die Daten zugänglich zu machen. Und das.
Ich kenne das, also ne, dieses Problem wird man auch nicht los, wenn man Verschlüsselung ordentlich macht, dann muss.
Ein äh müssen die Schlüssel sicher aufbewahrt werden und wenn man das jetzt irgendwie, wie es hier bei Luca gemacht wird, potentiell äh.
Zehntausende oder hunderttausenden gastronomischen Einrichtungen ermöglichen möchte,
da muss man sich über dieses Problem eben leider Gedanken machen, ne? Und ich weiß nicht deren Lösung, ich weiß nur, dass sie
entweder das Problem haben werden, dass irgendwelche gastronomischen Einrichtungen Schlüsse für ihre Materialien nicht mehr finden, wenn's mal angefragt wird
oder dass sie irgendeine Möglichkeit haben, da doch noch eine äh den Schlüssel dann wieder herzustellen. Da gibt's tausend Wege, aber ähm,
keiner von denen ist so richtig schön und die basieren immer darauf und das ist der ähm,
der der grundsätzliche Teil, dass man Luca vertraut, weil man keinen unabhängigen Vertrauensanker hat
und deswegen Luca machen könnte, was sie wollen. Ähm das heißt nicht, ne, spezifisch nicht, dass sie es tun würden, ja, oder dass sie irgendetwas böses im Schilde führen, möchte nur betonen
die müssen ihren Kram richtig machen. Und üblicherweise macht man Verschlüsselung in der Annahme.
Diejenigen, über die man kommuniziert ihren Kram nicht richtig machen und das ist der Grund, warum man
üblicherweise die Verschlüsselung und die Verifikation von Schlüsseln von der Anbieterin trennt. Ja, das ist die Idee, warum man verschlüsselt. Und dieses, wenn dieses Prinzip verletzt ist,
ähm dann hat man eben ja nicht unbedingt das, was man jetzt irgendwie eine Sortenreine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung,
äh
nennen kann, weil eben der Fall nicht spezifiziert ist, dass der Schlüssel einfach getauscht wurde. Und wie gesagt, wird's nicht unterstellen, aber das ist einfach ein ein ein dieser Architektur
inne wohnendes Problem und jetzt spekuliere ich, das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum die am Ende äh in den Meilen, wo wir geschaut haben, ähm,
noch allen Gesundheitsämtern den gleichen Schlüssel gegeben haben und es auch einen Lukatest-Account gab, der ebenfalls diesen Schlüssel hatte.
Was dann die zweite äh Ebene der Verschlüsselung letztendlich äh unnütz macht?
Da sagen sie ja immer diesen, diesen, dass die sich als Gesundheitsamt angemeldet haben, das war nur zu Testzwecken. Ähm aber ich fand's ganz spannend, weil das zeigt ja schon, dieses Ding mit dem Vertrauen und für mich als Journalistin war's auch super interessant zu sehen, dass das wirklich ein Punkt ist.
Alle einig sind, also die Datenschutzkonferenz, wo er diese Task Force, wo er verschiedene Landesdatenschützer drin waren und sich wohl ziemlich lange ziemlich gestritten haben, was jetzt genau die Position ist.
Zur Luca-App entsprechend wachsweich ist die Erklärung, die sie gegeben haben, aber was deutlich drin steht, die zentrale Datenspeicherung ist ein Problem.
Und äh und das bringt große Gefahren mit sich, die und ihre Kollegin von der EPFL haben das ausgiebig dargelegt und eben auch gesagt.
Man muss der ähm dem Anbieter vertrauen ähm das ist das ist der einzige Weg und das ist äh bei einfach solchen Mengen an sensiblen Daten und und auch noch Gesundheitsdaten natürlich eine.
Hat auch gefährlich oder ist er auch gefährlich? Und sogar ähm dieser äh Pentest Provider, den Luca selbst beauftragt hat, diese eher NRW. Auch die haben haben das in ihrem Bericht wirklich sehr prominent und sehr, sehr deutlich geschrieben, dass das ein sehr zentrales Problem ist.
Nicht umgangen werden kann bei einer zentralen Datenspeicherung. Und also da war für mich klar, okay, wenn wenn's wirklich aus allen Ecken kommt,
also das ist ja was wie wie schätzen wir Journalistinnen so Themen ein? Ich bin kann nicht coden, ich bin auch keine Informatikerin,
Aber wenn alle Seiten sagen, das ist ein Problem, dann ist es eins, ne? Also dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass das wahr ist und dass man das auch nicht wegdiskutieren kann. Und das finde ich gerade,
ziemlich anstrengend, weil natürlich die Luka-Leute immer versuchen, das wegzudiskutieren, am liebsten mit dem Argument, ach komm, wir sind doch nicht böse, wir wollen doch nur Gutes tun. Und äh das ist natürlich kein Argument, ja, das Einfache, wirklich kein Argument.
Dazu kommt ja, dass es inzwischen verschiedene ähm.
Hinweise gibt, dass sie natürlich, ich meine, es ist ein Start-up, das sie natürlich irgendein Business Case da dahinter haben, der auch länger hält, als die Pandemie.
Weil natürlich wird irgendwann das contact tracing oder diese Eventverfolgung nicht nicht mehr so relevant sein, dann werden die Bundesländer nicht mehr bereit sein, dafür weiß ich nicht wie viel Millionen Geld auszugeben. Äh das heißt, dann brauchen die jemand anders, der.
Sie bezahlt.
Das ist natürlich was, was zu Recht völlig misstrauisch machen sollte, ganz egal, was sie da vorhaben. Mit irgendwas wollen die auch mal Geld machen, jenseits von der Pandemie.
Ja und diese zwei Punkte machen, also die finde ich, sind einfach sehr, sehr starke Argumente gegen so eine Lösung.
Da machen sie ja also, ne, für eine dauerhaft belastbares äh Geschäftsmodell,
gibt's auch in dieser Werbebroschüre, die ich hier vor mir habe, durchaus Hinweise, ja? Das haben wir auch in einer der früheren Folgen Lokbuch Netzkritik besprochen, als wir über die Schweiz gesprochen haben, wo es,
ein System gab, was äh ja auch Realdaten erfasst hat und dieses System wurde dann von einem Tickethändler gekauft, also sowas wie Eventim im Prinzip, die gesagt haben, ach Mensch, das ist doch praktisch.
Ne
QR-Code-Scanner überall. Da können wir jetzt Einlass mitmachen. Wenn sich jetzt erstmal sogar jede Kneipe da dran gewöhnt hat, dann wollen sie's vielleicht auch irgendwann nicht mehr missen und dann ist es ja auch noch nur noch ein Schritt, wenn sie's eh schon da stehen haben, darüber zum Beispiel auch ein Ticketvorverkauf zu machen und solche Dinge, ne, was ja durch.
Also wer jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, dass es nicht etwas wäre, woran Menschen ähm Interesse haben und äh das ist hier
bei denen schon auf der Roadmap, dass sie sagen, übrigens ab dem ersten April, in dem, in dem Status, den ich hier noch habe, hm, Luka bietet eine Schnittstelle, um Tickets direkt in der App
und wenn gewünscht, im Luka QR-Code zu verwenden, äh ne.
Naheliegend, sie wären ja auch blöd, wenn sie es nicht machen würden, wenn du sagst, du möchtest für Venus äh interessant sein, hier im Beispiel für das Fußballspiel zwischen Holstein Kiel und dem FC Bayern München und
Die Deutschlandtour der fantastischen vier. Ja, dass man dann natürlich auch äh den,
den Eintritt auch direkt daran bindet an den,
Check-In und natürlich auch äh Ideen stehen, wie ja, wir möchten mhm,
ja vielleicht auch Impfpässe und sonstige Scherze, alles alles in diesem einen System abbilden, wo du dann eben mit einem.
QR-Code alles geklärt hast.
Das ist natürlich.
Problematisch aus zwei Gründen, ne? Erstens diese ganzen digitalen Kontaktverfolgungsunterstützungssysteme sind immer mit dieser Prämisse ins Feld geführt worden mit, wenn die Pandemie vorbei ist, dann schalten wir das alles wieder ab.
Ist das alles weg und dann ist es so wieder so wie vorher und das ist jetzt eine Ausnahmesituation. In dem Moment, wo natürlich diese App sich dann sozusagen in was anderes äh verwandelt, kann man jetzt nicht wirklich sagen, dass diese Infrastruktur weg ist.
Natürlich auch erstmal äh weiter existiert und dann für andere Dinge auf einmal verwendet wird, die eigentlich jetzt erstmal nicht im Fokus stehen. Zweite Problem, was ich sehe, ist.
Aus welchem Grund wird jetzt sozusagen ein Hersteller hier durch diese Sondersituation äh von staatlicher Seite her finanziell hochgepäppelt und damit sozusagen als Superstart abgeadelt.
Und damit auf einmal ohne dass jetzt der Staat auch irgendwelche Rechte daran hat. Also ich meine, hier werden Lizenzen gekauft. Das ist eher etwas, was was ich sehr schwierig finde, ja.
Zinsen woran? Also man lädt ja die App immer noch aus dem App Store runter wie sonst auch
Also, was genau ist jetzt sozusagen die Lizensierung,
der Staat benutzt ja diesen Code nicht. Er schreibt daran nichts, er gibt auch keine Vorgaben dafür, was denn äh an Funktionalität dort drin zu sein hat, enthält keine Rechte äh da dran. Also es ist sozusagen
vollkommen unklar, mir zumindest, was jetzt eigentlich genau lizensiert wird, weil der Staat ja eigentlich gar nichts nutzt.
Hat weißt du, ich habe dir da Erkenntnisse, was was da die Formulierung ist?
Also ich kenne die Verträge nicht, aber ich würde jetzt eigentlich das so verstehen,
für das laufende Kalenderjahr, in dem er die Gastronomie noch nicht geöffnet hat oder einen anders definierten Zeitraum. Äh,
die Lizenz zur Nutzung durch die Gesundheitsämter des Landes sowie die im Lande befinden gastronomischen Einrichtungen. So würde ich jetzt die ähm.
Eine Lizenz verstehen.
Aber die Nutzung von was genau? Was nutzen denn die Gesundheitsämter.
Also die die.
Programmiert dann Luca Software für die Gesundheitsämter, die die dann benutzen können.
Ja ja, die nutzen also die die Gesundheitsämter nutzen Luka ÖGD.
Ja, Schlüsselmanagement, Datenaustausch mit Sormas, äh Nachverfolgung im Gesundheitsamt durchführen. Das ist äh das äh Luka ÖGD,
damit arbeiten die Gesundheitsamtmitarbeiter, die Luca-App ist für alle kostenlos, klar, ne, da wo du wo du nicht der Kunde bist, äh sondern die Ware, kriegst es umsonst. Und ähm Luca Locations ist das Management-Tool für Betreiberinnen, um
potentiell auch mehrere Standorte zu verwalten. Und mein Verständnis ist, dass die Lizenz umfasst die äh Nutzung durch die Gesundheitsämter
und die äh kostenlose Nutzung durch die gastronomischen Einrichtungen des Landes und den Hahn abdrehen kannst du hier ganz einfach, indem du dieses Luca ÖGD dann abschaltest, weil damit wird die Nutzung durch jedes Restaurant ebenfalls uninteressant.
Und äh ne, also dadurch würde ich quasi, wenn das jetzt, ne, wenn wenn Manuela Schwesig nicht zahlt, dann würde ich halt den Hahn zudrehen ähm im Luka ÖGD und dann hat sich das auch äh sofort wieder erledigt. Gleichzeitig wird
Manuela Schwesig das im Zweifelsfall nicht tun, weil sie es ja selber ausgerollt hat und damit eben nächstes Jahr äh einen Fehler eingestehen müsste, wenn sie es nicht verlängert. Insofern wird sie sicherlich,
dann eben verlängern und so funktionieren ja Abofallen auch.
Das ist übrigens das Licht, super interessant, Stichwort Abo-Falle, also genau das Wort, das ist auch gefallen. Ähm von äh von äh Lokalpolitikern.
Äh denen Luca angeboten wurde und das ist auch.
Zentrales, also willst du was sagen, Herzstück der Marketingstrategie, die wirklich perfide ist und die die ganz viele Leute, glaube ich, nicht durch, die man lange auch nicht durchschauen konnte.
Gesagt hat, ja, wir machen das doch quasi selbstlos, weil wir wollen vor allem der armes Mudo möchte ja wieder auf seine Tournee gehen können. Wir wollen, ey, wir wollen echt die Kulturbranche retten. Es ist für alle kostenlos und dann haben sie ja jetzt übers letzte halbe Jahr,
die App verschenkt in Anführungszeichen, also ich weiß, ihr kennt das Beispiel von Sylt.
Wo sie mit der Tourismusagentur, wie die vor Ort heißt, eben den Deal gemacht haben, Mensch guck, ihr kriegt das alles kostenlos, dann können bei euch wieder Touristen kommen, weil ihr könnt super gut die Nachverfolgung machen.
Mich haben Leute von Sylt kontaktiert, die zu so Privatpersonen, die das einfach kritisch sehen, auch nach der kritischen Berichterstattung unter anderem von mir,
die gesagt haben, ich habe keine Chance auf Sylt. Ähm da äh was dagegen zu sagen, weil ich werde niedergeschrien von meinen Landsleuten, weil natürlich alle wollen raus, alle wollen Touristen, man ist dort wahnsinnig abhängig vom Tourismus,
versprochen und das ist glaub ich auch schon seit Herbst so dass dass die Marketing quasi diese,
Luca-App nutzt und verbreitet, mit dem versprechen wir, wir kommen raus aus dem Lockdown, Leute können wiederkommen. Äh und und erst dann wurde irgendwann klar, ja und äh.
Wenn das aber weiter laufen soll, also Luca hat gesagt, dann machen sie's mal ein halbes Jahr oder das ist das Beispiel, was ich kenne von einem anderen Kreis, wo sie es wir geben's euch einfach mal ein halbes Jahr kostenlos, testet doch einfach mal ähm.
Wir sind da ganz entspannt und ganz frei und wir wollen wirklich einfach eine gute Lösung verbreiten. Testet mal und dann kommt raus, ja aber kaufen muss es eben das Bundesland. Und ich meine, da hat natürlich das Bundesland,
braucht auch ein anderes als die, die was die bisher hatten, um zu sagen
Nee, die Lösung ist funktioniert nicht. Ich habe gehört, die hat Sicherheitslücken und ist überhaupt zentrale Speicherung ist nicht gut. Wenn die ganze Insel Sylt zum Beispiel aufschreit und sagt, spinnt ihr, wir haben jetzt damit angefangen, das funktioniert, wir wollen das haben, weil das hilft uns ja aus dem Lockdown raus.
Also das waren, finde ich, eine wirklich eine perfide Art und Weise, da Druck aufzubauen, hintenrum immer mit diesem schönen wir wollen hier doch nur die Welt retten und wir schenken euch jetzt erstmal alles und dann klar, dann kommt jetzt auf einmal die Rechnung für die Bundesländer und wie gesagt, eins Komma fünf.
Zehn Komma fünf Millionen Euro wurden allein von sechs Bundesländern jetzt schon bezahlt und wie du sagst, wenn wenn das dann ins nächste Jahr geht,
dann sind die ja auch derart abhängig, dass man auch nicht weiß, was passiert, wenn der Preis auf einmal steigt. Also wer.
Da sind die Machtverhältnisse schon auch ganz klar auf der Seite derer, die äh also auf Lukas Seite, die sagen genau, wir hätten gerne doch noch ein bisschen mehr. Also man macht sich abhängig. Es ist ja wie wie eine klassische Abo-Falle. Du kaufst eine Sache und wenn du's dann.
So richtig dran gewöhnt hast und all deine Daten drin sind, ähm dann kannst du eigentlich nicht anders, als es zu verlängern, noch mal zu kaufen und dann wird's teurer.
Aber habe ich das jetzt gerade richtig äh verstanden? Das wäre für mich ja sogar, äh muss ich sagen, eine Neuigkeit, dass die schon mal einen funktionierenden Wirkbetrieb auf Sylt hatten.
Oder war das auch schon nach dem äh Insult schon wieder der der Bordstein hochgeklappt war?
Ist es nicht so, dass man auf Sylt, dass dass da Touristen gerade wieder hinkommen? Ich weiß es auch nicht sicher. Das hatte ich jetzt auch nur aus dem Bekanntenkreis gehört. Ähm vielleicht war's auch einfach das Versprechen und die Leute dort haben angefangen, das aufzubauen. Das weiß ich nicht, hundert.
Also.
Weil mir also auch da, ich weiß, mir ist gar nicht bekannt, äh wo das jetzt mal richtig funktioniert hätte, schon mal irgendwo zu sehen gewesen wäre, weil ähm.
Auf meiner mentalen Landkarte tauchte dieses Luca irgendwann im äh Dezember auf
äh da gab's dann auch ein Tagesthemenbeitrag dazu mit Smudo und Tim Mälzer, ja, also ich muss wirklich,
bin ja wirklich auch ein bisschen beeindruckt davon, ja, von dieser Marketingstrategie, dass sie halt es schaffen, einen Tagesthemenbeitrag mit Smudo und Tim Mälzer zu positionieren. Ähm.
Über dieses äh über diese App und das war eben im Dezember
zwanzig zwanzig und dann habe ich auch gedacht, na okay, dann ist das Thema jetzt auch wieder durch, brauch ja gerade niemand. Aber jetzt haben wir
bald äh jetzt ist es Anfang April, das heißt seit drei Monaten rührt er eine durchgängige Werbetrommel und nach meinem Verständnis ist zumindest in diesen drei Monaten ja keine ähm.
Keine Gastronomie irgendwo geöffnet gewesen.
Du hast recht. Ja, du hast Recht, ich habe mich besonnen, das stimmt. Dieses Beispiel mit Sylt ist tatsächlich auch ähm ist ist äh einfach eine schöne Idee und soweit ich weiß, eben dort schon ausgerollt und bereit dafür,
Aber wie stimmt, es darf soweit ich weiß, dürfen noch nirgendwo jetzt auch Touristen hin. Ähm aber was ich gehört habe, ist eben auch Luca wirbt damit, das wird ja schon getestet hier und da Jena spielt sich da sehr in den Vordergrund, was ich sehr interessant finde mit dem Argument, wir haben ja schon,
Testläufe und wenn man genauer hinguckt, kommt raus, na ja ähm nicht so richtig, ne? Die haben halt eine Behörde, Halbzeit mal genutzt und äh die Stadtbücherei war mal ganz kurz geöffnet, da wurde so ein bisschen getestet, aber es gab.
War das so das vom Gesundheitsamt, dass es kein einziges gab, wo mal die ganze Kette funktioniert hat? Also es gibt es gibt keine Testung. Ähm niemand weiß, ob das funktioniert.
Aber nicht so desto trotz wird so hingestellt, ne? Das ist von läuft ja schon. Kann ja, kann ja alles schon.
Das ist echt auch eine sportliche Herangehensweise, also im ne,
wenn man schon wenn die an, wenn die Konkurrentinnen von Luca schon keinen äh bekannten Rapper haben, haben die zumindest äh ein paar Monate funktionierenden Wirkbetrieb.
Ja? Wenn sie schon länger im Markt sind.
Das stimmt. Also unsere Recherche haben wir mit mit App-Betreibern gesprochen, die teilweise schon seit April letzten Jahres.
Genau, also ihre App auf dem Markt oder am Start haben und tatsächlich zeigen konnten, dass es funktioniert. Ja, das stimmt.
Ja und das also das war was, was uns eben, als wir diese Recherche geschaut, als ich diese auch als ich diese erste Recherche gestartet habe, was mich so.
Erstaunt hat. Also Luca kam wie wie für dich Linus für mich auch so aus dem Nichts geschossen und auf einmal war es total bekannt.
Denkt man, ja gut, es ist halt Smudo, natürlich ist der bekannt, aber ähm es geht ja auch um es geht ja auch darum, ob's funktioniert und wie es funktioniert. Und das fand ich sehr erschreckend.
Und das ist auch so ein schon auch so ein Alarmzeichen gewesen, wo ich dachte, okay, da ist eine Geschichte dahinter. Wie kann das sein, dass,
meine meine Filterblase von ernsthaften Security Forscherinnen in Anführungszeichen, in Anführungszeichen deshalb, weil weil Luca sich über meinen ersten Artikel sehr beschwert hat, weil ich,
sagt, da hat noch kein ernsthafte, kein ernsthafte Security-Forscherin draufgeschaut. Also diese Filterblase.
Forscherinnen hat getobt, dass es äh gefährlich und unsicher äh schon aufgrund also lang bevor der Code, der jetzt erst ja tröpfchenweise quasi äh öffentlich gemacht wird, so lange vorher schon, also alle nach den Sachen auf den Sachen, die sie halt Reverse Engineering konnten,
getobt und gesagt, dass es äh ganz gefährlich, ganz schlecht gemacht.
Parallel dazu eben diese diese mediale Maschinerie, in der immer wieder Smudo aufgetauscht sind, Versprechungen gemacht hat, ähm die dazu geführt hat, aus undurchsichtigen Gründen, dass tatsächlich jetzt.
Bundesländer lassen mich lügen, also zwölf sind's mindestens äh eine Zusage gemacht haben und äh Verträge gemacht haben mit Luca.
Und das hat mich also das sowas macht mich dann misstrauisch. Natürlich als Journalistin, was ist da im Hintergrund geschehen?
Die Unterlagen, die ich dann zugespielt bekommen habe, die haben schon auch gezeigt, dass da eben im Hintergrund schon seit Oktober verhandelt wurde und in einigen Bundesländern auch auch versucht wurde.
Übliche Ausschreibungspraxis zu umgehen, indem unter anderem, also das Beispiel Thüringen fand ich eigentlich am, am, am, am krassesten.
Immer gesagt wurde, ja wir müssen halt wir müssen das halt so darstellen, wir müssen halt zeigen, dass Luca die einzige Lösung am Markt ist, die das die das kann.
Dann dürfen wir das machen, obwohl sogar diese diese Ausnahmeregelung, die es ja gibt, auf die man sich dann auch immer beruft, ob aufgrund von von Corona ähm vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium, die besagt, dass man klassische Ausschreibungen nicht machen muss, aber.
Muss immer mindestens drei Angebote vergleichen, eben außer es gibt wirklich keinen einzigen weiteren Anbieter, der das Gleiche kann.
Zumindest in Thüringen wurde dieser Beweis, dass es keinen einzigen anderen Anbieter gibt. Angetreten, indem man Luca gefragt hat, könnt ihr uns das bestätigen.
Wir haben die E-Mail gesehen. Äh Luka hat das bestätigt und das wurde dann als Vergabevermerkt zu den Akten gelegt.
Hat ja offenbar Thüringen, dann haben wir gesehen, Thüringen als eins der wenigen Länder sich umentschieden, weil's da offenbar intern Widerstände gab. Ich vermute, so kam ich auch zu diesen Unterlagen und diesen E-Mails.
Aber das hat so einen Einblick gegeben, wie so was abläuft, ja? Und Smudo hat im Interview mit uns ganz offen gesagt, na klar, er hat gute Kontakte und er hat so eine ähm.
Überzeugende Art. Die hat er ja unbestritten auch. Der kann ja gut reden. Er hat natürlich das alles genutzt, seine Kontakte, dadurch kam er zu Maischberger, das war die erste von diesen drei Talkshows,
Ich vermute, darüber kam er dann in die anderen beiden, wenn er nicht da selber auch noch direkte Kontakte hatte. Also er hat diese Kontakte natürlich genutzt. Er hat Politiker kennengelernt und angequatscht und vielleicht auch schon gekannt. Das äh konnten wir es nicht äh eindeutig nachweisen.
Aber hat über diese Kontakte natürlich die Diskussion im Hintergrund vorangetrieben und das seit Oktober.
Vor dem Hintergrund fand ich's echt auch nochmal spannend, jetzt zu hören, dass manche Bundesländer zum Beispiel Mecklenburg,
auch gesagt haben, es war keine Zeit für eine ordentliche Ausschreibung, das Dauer der Monate, aber seit Oktober ist es halt ein halbes Jahr bis jetzt und ja, also dann hätte sogar Monate gehabt, um eine Ausschreibung zu machen und auch Mecklenburg auch da,
mir Unterlagen vor, die zeigen, dass es die Marktprüfung, die die gemacht haben, äh basiert auf paar Textblöcken, die sie von Websites, von eben diesen Startups kopiert haben,
Außer Luca, da ist es ein bisschen ausführlicher wie durch Zufall. In dem Dokument und dann kommt am Ende raus, Luca sind die Einzigen, die es können und da weiß ich jetzt von, darf ich rein, die mir das gesagt haben, ein anderes Start-up.
Wir haben das Dokument auch gesehen, dass ihre App da falsch dargestellt wurde. Sie werden Sachen unterschlagen, die sie auch können.
Und was ich jetzt in den aktuellen Recherche rausbekommen habe, und was eigentlich der Höhepunkt ist.
Zehn Bundesländer haben jetzt seinen Vertrag gemacht auf Grundlage von so 'nem so 'ner Verhandlung von Dataport, dieser Bundes-IT Dienstleister oder für die nördlichen Bundesländer.
Da habe ich gefragt, bei Dataport, wie kam denn das zustande? Gab's da eigentlich eine Ausschreibung? Und die haben mir gesagt, nee, ähm.
Grundlage war unter anderem die Markterkundung von einem unserer Trägerländer und die haben paar Trägerländer und eben Mecklenburg-Vorpommern als eins.
Habe ich gesagt, ja, war das zufällig Mecklenburg, die die Grundlage oh, das kann ich ihr nicht sagen. Also das wollten sie nicht verraten. Jetzt habe ich inzwischen hat aus Niedersachsen, glaube ich,
Lokalpolitiker hat inzwischen verraten, dass das tatsächlich, also dass die Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Markterkundung diese zusammengekopierten Textblöcke aus dem Internet,
ohne dass die anderen Apps auch nur einmal kontaktiert worden sind, zumindest von darf ich rein, weiß ich, dass er sie nicht mal angesprochen wurden, obwohl sie's angeboten haben, dass das diese Markterkundung ist, die angeblich rechtfertigt, dass es keinen weiteren, keinen zweiten Anbieter gibt, der die,
Voraussetzungen erfüllt. Und da war ich schon echt ein bisschen schockiert. Also man hört ja auf, dass vieles hinten rumläuft in der Politik, aber das so eins zu eins.
Sehen, wie Sachen, also aus meiner Sicht wird wurden nicht hingedreht. Da hat offenbar jemand gefunden, dass eine gute Lösung und da darf man jetzt spekulieren, was denjenigen beeinflusst hat, aber das kann natürlich gut sein, dass die guten Kontakte,
Von Smudo deine Rolle gespielt haben. Jemand hat beschlossen, dass es, wir wollen das und jetzt drehen wir alles so hin, dass wir sagen können, wir können das direkt vergeben.
Und das finde ich echt schon einen Skandal, also unabhängig von der Frage, ob diese fünfzig anderen Start-ups eine bessere Lösung haben, weil natürlich das auch zentrale Lösungen sind und auch.
In Frage steht, ob wir das überhaupt wollen. Aber allein, dass sowas so durchgeboxt wird, finde ich wirklich erschreckend.
Da gibt's doch dieses wunderschöne Zitat von Michael Müller, dem äh regierenden Oberbürgermeister von Berlin, der dann in einem Fernsehgespräch auch sagt, also,
ich habe auch jetzt für Luca unterschrieben und das, obwohl ich noch nicht mal mit Smudo geredet habe oder von den technischen Details,
und von den technischen Details auch keine Ahnung habe, weil wenn das was ist, was uns helfen kann, dann müssen wir es auch machen. Und
Äh das ist ja, also das ist ja auch wieder ein Fraktal aus äh aus Auffälligkeiten. Äh ein solcher Satz, ähm also als wäre es relevant, mit Smudo darüber zu sprechen, der ja spezifisch auch sagt,
er wiederum davon keine Ahnung hat, sondern ähm ja, vielleicht kannst du mir das ganz kurz noch sagen. Eva, was macht eigentlich der Smudo da? Was ist eigentlich dessen Rolle in dem ganzen Gefüge?
Also wir haben ja mit ihm dann auch, also die haben sich ziemlich empört über meinen ersten Artikel für Zeit online und haben gesagt, sie wollen äh.
Jetzt wirklich mit mir sprechen, was lustig war, weil ich hatte tatsächlich auch mit ihnen sprechen wollen für den ersten Artikel und der Termin wurde abgesagt und es war dann offenbar keine Priorität neu zu finden. Daraufhin habe ich das Interview schriftlich geführt und.
Antworten bekommen, die dann zitiert, dann war's ihnen irgendwie nicht recht, dass die da dass äh die nicht so gut da standen, weil das das habe ich den anderen habe ich auch, dass Modus nicht gewöhnt ist.
Kritisiert zu werden. Ich glaube er ist einfach gewohnt so gut anzukommen mit seiner überzeugenden Art.
Wie er selber sagt, dass ja, dass er damit nicht klarkommt. Und als seine Artikel erschienen war, dann wollten sie auf einmal sehr dringend mit mir reden und haben das also quasi per Twitter auch eingefordert fast schon.
Also haben wir ein Gespräch gehabt und da hat da habe ich dann gefragt, was war denn oder haben wir gefragt, was hat's denn eigentlich genau für eine Rolle? Und also er ist das eine ist natürlich, er ist Investor, er ist zu, weiß ich nicht, zwanzig Prozent ungefähr, ähm einfach beteiligt.
Und natürlich ist er Marketing-Figur. Er sagt immer, natürlich er kennt sich doch auch technisch aus, er hätte die Idee gehabt, dass man doch sowas irgendwie technisch lösen können muss, aber er hat natürlich nicht mitprogrammiert, also was ja aus meiner Sicht ist, ist es eben Marketingfigur.
Der ist euch auch richtig aufgehoben, ne? Also das und das kann man ihm noch nicht mal. Also ich finde, natürlich kann man ihm das gar nicht mehr richtig vorwerfen, weil er, also er investiert und macht, natürlich macht natürlich Werbung. Er hat ja Interesse daran, dass dieses Unternehmen erfolgreich läuft, was ich halt schlimm finde, ist, dass.
Dass offenbar viele Politiker aber einfach komplett ausblenden, also dass die das eins zu eins für bare Münze nehmen, was sagt.
Ohne zu reflektieren, dass er Investor ist und beteiligt ist und dass er da Interesse hat. Und das finde ich.
Finde ich schlimm. Und da finde ich, hat er eben dann doch eine Verantwortung, weil er das ja weiß. Also er weiß ja um seine Wirkung.
Ja, also er wird hier schon so ein bisschen wie so ein Halsbringer äh auch ins Feld geführt, ne. In diesem Bereich des magischen
Denkens. Man hat sich mit dem Thema nicht so befasst, aber man hat das mal bestellt, weil man hat gelesen, dass es irgendwie alles gut macht.
Und äh dann wird halt äh das Schlangenöl gekauft
ohne sich jetzt darüber Gedanken zu machen, was es denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich in dem Prozess wirklich verbessern soll. Weil was mir ja noch so ein bisschen schleierhaft ist
Wie realistisch ist denn das bitte, dass hier wirklich ein Prozess in Gang kommt, der uns auch hilft? Also abgesehen davon.
Diese ganze Kontakterfassung ohnehin äh problematisch ist, in dem Moment, wo das Gesundheitsam
dann das alles nachgehen soll, ja? Klar, Zettel ablesen und dann Schrift zu entziffern, ist nochmal eine Extrahürde. Aber allein äh die Reaktionszeit, die das Gesundheitsamt in der aktuellen Pandemiesituation,
gezeigt hat, äh,
gibt mir wenig Hoffnung, dass hier irgendwas verhindert werden kann, wenn denn dann äh zeitnah Zugriff auf diese Listen kommt.
Nicht komplett ausschließen. Ich sage nur, ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel,
Zweitens habe ich auch noch ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass diese technische Anbindung an diese Gesundheitsämter funktioniert, wo wir Anfang dieses Jahres grade noch das Einstellen der letzten Faxübertragung an das RKI gefeiert haben,
Ja, also das ist ja sozusagen äh die andere Frage. Ich,
ich will jetzt, ich will jetzt, ich will jetzt auch gleich nochmal auf die neue Funktion in der Corona-Warn-App äh kommen, aber vielleicht können wir ja diesen Punkt nochmal so ein bisschen beleuchten.
Also ich würde mich da sofort anschließend, dass jetzt also bei allem,
was man denen, also die Gesundheitsämter haben hier viel geleistet und sind stark überlastet, ne? Aber was sie haben jetzt nicht durch besondere Digitalisierungsschübe
oder besondere Beschleunigungen äh von sich reden gemacht, ne? Wir haben immer noch eine Zeit, in der
Montags die Coronazahlen nicht stimmen, weil oder nicht
den das tatsächliche Infektionsgeschehen widerspiegeln, weil die Gesundheitsämter, die am Wochenende nicht liefern, ähm wir haben immer noch eine Situation, wo die nicht alle auf einem gemeinsamen digitalen Standard arbeiten
an den ähm äh diese Luca-App anbinden will heißt Sormas und Sormas ist nicht überall im Einsatz. So, dass
Es mag sein, dass äh irgendwo in einzelnen Gesundheitsämtern ganz besondere Excel-Zauberer arbeiten, die Sommers, äh was besseres als Sommers gemacht haben, ne. Ähm,
Aber ja, die also Innovation und Geschwindigkeit sind jetzt nicht die primär Attribute des Gesundheitsamtes. Ähm es hat einfach was mit der ähm.
Mit der gesetzlichen Notwendigkeit der Meldung an diese Gesundheitsämter zu tun und ich denke, das ist doch hier.
Eigentlich das zugrunde liegende Problem, dass man nämlich sagt, äh und das habe ich auch übrigens damals in dem,
äh Tagesthemen-Interview gesagt, wo äh ich mein mein meine Gedanken zu diesem Smudo und Tim Mälzer Auftritt äh abgeben musste. Wir haben.
Eine Regierung,
diese Regierung hat eine eigene Corona-App und sie hat eine Verordnung zur Erfassung von Kontaktdaten in gastronomischen Einrichtungen, die,
sie durch diese App nicht abdeckt, ja? Oder die dieser äh App auch entgegensteht und es läge ja eigentlich an der äh Bundesregierung, zum Beispiel zu sagen,
Übrigens ähm brauchen wir nicht, ne? Wir wir verzichten jetzt auf äh den die Pflicht,
zur ähm Erfassung der Adressdaten,
und ersetzen die durch eine Erfassung in sagen wir mal ein System wie Crowd Notifyer, dass wir in,
die Corona-Warn-App einbauen, ne? Das wäre eine absolut nachvollziehbare und sinnvolle Handlung und die eine Hälfte davon haben sie ja sogar gemacht, dass sie nämlich jetzt bald ein anonymes Check-In System in die Corona-Warn-App einbauen,
und ihre eigenen Investition aber nicht gerecht werden, indem sie dann sagen, oh ja und jetzt müssen wir nochmal ein paar Millionen in Richtung Nexen You kippen, damit wir unserem eigenen Gesetz entsprechen können. Also das ist äh äh ähm,
auch ein bisschen äh überraschend.
Ja und also das ist tatsächlich.
Interessant, weil das Hauptargument, warum das ja nicht ausreichen würde, dieses Update von der Corona-Warn-App, ist eben, weil das dann nicht mehr übers Gesundheitsamt läuft, also weil nicht das Gesundheitsamt dann verifizierte Telefonnummern bekommt und Menschen anrufen kann.
Wissen wir aber alle, dass es Gesundheitsamt ähm gar nicht hinterher kommt, Menschen anzurufen. Also das kennen wir glaube ich alle ausm ausm Bekanntenkreis Fälle, wo Leute erst nach.
Offiziellen Quarantänezeit überhaupt vom Gesundheitsamt Bescheid bekommen haben, weil die nicht hinterherkommen und das kann man denen vielleicht gar nicht vorwerfen, weil's einfach gerade sehr viel ist.
Aber man kann das natürlich lösen, indem man die Ämter ausm Prozess rausnimmt und diese Aufgabe eine App überträgt. Was, nämlich die Corona-Warn-App mit dem Update,
genau machen könnte, also die könnte genau das erfüllen, dass sie Menschen warnt, die im gleichen Restaurant waren, wenn sie diese App natürlich hatten, nur dann. Die haben ja aber inzwischen relativ viel und ich glaube, wenn man die noch ein bisschen.
Aktiver bewerben würde, was jetzt ja leider auch nicht passiert von der Politik, also es gibt ja auch Stimmen, die sagen, die haben bewusst die immer kleiner geredet und auch nicht weiter gepflegt. Ähm.
Also wenn man die bewerben würde, würden's auch noch mehr Leute haben. Und dann bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, könnte man mehr Menschen,
erreichen über diese nämlich sehr, sehr schnelle Warnung, die die Corona-Warn-App ja macht. Also das ist das ist ja äh positiver Test rein, zack, andere Nutzer sind gewarnt
im Vergleich zum Gesundheitsamt, was was im Woche braucht, also nicht alle, sind klar, nicht alle Ämter, manche sind da auch super schnell.
Aber oft geht's eben auch langsamer und ich denke, ein Tag oder zwei,
auf jeden Fall ins Land im Vergleich dazu. Und wie gesagt, dass ihr mit Anrufen hier hinterherkommen, erfahren's manche Menschen auch einfach nie. Auch jetzt über ich weiß auch, über Gesundheitsamtsgrenzen hinweg war das lange schwierig und das ist, glaube ich, immer noch, dass es zumindest Zeit kostet. Also wenn du in einem Landkreis jemanden.
Im Restaurant warst oder jemanden getroffen hast, der der Kontakt eins von dem bist, dass dann dein Gesundheitsamt das erfährt und dir Bescheid sagt, das kostet auch nochmal Zeit. Und all diese Grenzen kennt ja so eine App nicht. Also das heißt.
Wir würden Menschen sehr viel schneller erreichen und jetzt ist wieder das beliebte Argument der.
Äh Smudo und Co. Ja, aber Freiwilligkeit funktioniert ja nicht. Wer geht schon freiwillig in Quarantäne? Und da würde ich sagen, hey, jeder jeder Mensch kennt inzwischen oder hat, hat welche, die er schützen möchte, ja, also jede zumindest, also selbst wenn man egoistisch denkt.
Möchte dann derjenige seine Mutter nicht anstecken oder seine Kinder nicht oder was auch immer sein Asthma-Krankenpartner.
Also äh lässt er sich doch zumindest testen oder ist zumindest, wie du sagst, vorher äh sagt die Copro für den Abend ab und lässt lässt sich testen stattdessen. Also ich bin mir sicher, dass man damit mehr erreichen würde als über diesen Weg.
Gesundheitsämter, wir warten mal, bis sie soweit sind, anzurufen und die kommen mit den Daten nicht hinterher schon gar nicht, wenn jetzt geöffnet werden sollte und die dann Datenwurst äh von von Luca App Daten bekommen, wo nicht mal ganz klar ist, wie deren Kontext eigentlich ist und ob die überhaupt.
Sinnvoll sind.
Also in dem Argument wird ja auch wieder eigentlich alles auf den Kopf gestellt, weil wenn du also
wenn du nicht in Quarantäne möchtest oder wenn du äh na, irgendwie nicht deinen Leuten sagen möchtest, dass du krank bist oder was auch immer für Restriktionen oder Negatives, du erwartest, dann lässt du dich einfach nicht testen.
Ja und das ist äh ne, das ist der einfachste Weg, egal welche App du nutzt, ja? Das ist auch sehr interessant, wie es da ähm auf den Kopf gestellt wird.
Ein weiterer Aspekt, der ja auch sehr interessant diskutiert wurde. Ja, Eva, du hast ja schon gesagt, Smudo schein.
Einfach nicht gewohnt zu sein äh kritisiert zu werden. Ähm war die Sache mit dem okay, ey,
ne? Macht die mal Quell offen. Das Ding ist ja noch nicht einmal open. So die
die erste Antwort, die ich darauf noch in Erinnerung habe, war irgendwie so, ja, ey, das ist einfach Respektlosigkeit gegenüber geistigem Eigentum, ja? Äh was man ja von einem Musiker auch wieder gut verstehen kann, ne, der Respektlosigkeit gegenüber geistigen Eigentum beschäftigt Musiker ja immer wieder,
Und dann haben sie äh jetzt allerdings doch vor einigen Tagen den Quellcode,
auf Gitarb gestellt, auch nur von Teilen, nämlich von der App und ich glaube, Teile des Backens, wenn ich das ganze Backend haben, noch gefehlt, was jetzt auch, ne, von der Aussage der, also der vertrauensbildenden Maßnahme her,
eben auch, ja, killefit ist und haben das Ganze, äh, weil es jetzt Open-Source war, unter eine Lizenz gestellt.
Die sie sich selber ausgedacht haben und diese.
Lizenz erlaubte, das Betrachten des Quelltextes zu nicht-kommerziellen Zwecken.
Ja? Äh was also solche Lizenzen gibt es also gibt es nicht, ja und ähm.
Ich betrachte nur zu komme als geilen Zwecken. Wenn ich was anschaue, mache ich schon damit Geld.
Genau, du darfst da nicht drauf gucken. Du darfst es nicht machen, weil du bist ja, du handelst ja kommerziell als Journalistin, ne. Also wenn du da drauf geschaut hast, um darüber einen Artikel zu schreiben, was schon falsch. Ähm.
So schlecht wie ich bezahlt wird, sind das keine kommerziellen Zwecke, würde ich sagen. Das ist maximal eine Aufwandsentschädigung.
Scherz wurden sie auch äh also haben auch alle gesagt, so jetzt Leute, jetzt äh hört's aber halt auch wirklich mal auf, ne. Und ähm.
Bärenstark gehörte noch dazu, dann fand sich.
In dem Quelltext die Verwendung einer Library, einer Open Source Library, die,
unter der GPL drei steht, also der äh General Public Public Leistens, ne? Ist das, oder? Wo wofür steht GPL?
Genau, nur.
Also eine ähm Lizenz, die ähm den Grundgedanken hat, ansteckend zu sein. Nämlich wenn du etwas, was unter GPL steht.
In deinem Code verarbeitest und weiterverwendest, dann muss auch der wieder unter GPL stehen. Ja, das ist ein äh ähm
also eine erfordernis dieser Lizenz, du hast freien Zugriff, solange das, was du schaffst, auch wieder unter GPL steht. Alternativ kannst, musst du eben eine andere Einigung finden, aber das ist die öffentliche Lizenz.
Muss man sich ja schon Gedanken drüber machen, ob so eine Software dann auch der Infektionsschutzverordnung äh entspricht, wenn die so infektiösen Code enthält.
Ekelig. So, vor allem heißt es aber, ne, die die Lizenzentscheidung, unter welche Lizenz und urheberrechtlichen Bedingungen ich meinen Code stelle.
Ja ähm ne.
Die Entscheidung des oder derjenigen, die dieses geistige Eigentum hat. Und das gilt es natürlich zu respektieren. Und da kann man ja wirklich von einer absoluten.
Missachtung des geistigen Eigentums Dritter sprechen, wenn man hier nämlich die Lizenz nicht äh respektiert, ja? Ähm also hatten sie erstens einen äh
ja, Shitstorm ist, kann man gar nicht sagen, einfach nur ein Lachsturm wegen ihrer selbstgeklöppelten Lizenz da.
Und zweitens, direkt noch eine Urheberrechtsverletzung von demjenigen, dessen Code sie da gestohlen haben, beziehungsweise bei sich eingebaut haben, unter Verletzung,
von äh der der Lizenz, unter die der äh Urheberrechtseigentümer diesen Code gestellt hatte.
Ja? Und dann haben sie wieder dann sind sie auch noch hingegangen, haben gesagt, das ist eine Basisfunktionalität, das müssen wir nicht lizenzieren und das ist wirklich also das, das konntest du dir gar nicht angucken.
Ähm vor allem wenn du da jetzt mal, ich bin da ja noch äh äh sagen wir mal, ich äh lache da ja nur drüber, ne. Aber wenn du jetzt mal dir
darüber Gedanken machst, was die GPL für eine Bedeutung hatte in dem Entstehen von freier Software und was das für eine, ja
da verwende ich den Begriff jetzt mal nicht spöttisch, sondern wirklich eine eine Religion der Open Source ist, diese GPL, ja, die
in wichtiger zentraler Punkt für das Durchsetzen oder den Erfolg des Gnolinox äh Ökosystems war und diese GPL ist eigentlich die Basis, ne des freien Programmierwissens, da machst
eine GPL verletzt du nicht, Punkt. Das ist einfach, da steht so geschrieben und da hältst du dich auch dran, ja? Und ähm.
Das hat natürlich, sagen wir mal, Leute, die in dem im Programmieren und gerade im Programmieren seit Jahrzehnten tätig sind.
Für die ist das jetzt auch nicht irgendwie ein Scherz, mal eben eine GPL zu zu verletzen von jemandem, sondern das ist genau das, was mit dieser Lizenz verhindert werden soll und muss und wo auch keinerlei Schätzchen äh auch nur im geringsten toleriert werden.
Dafür gibt es ja diese Lizenz und deswegen ist das Open Source äh Ökosystem so stark, weil es sich hier lohnt, Qualität zu bauen, weil
eben genau sicher sein kannst, dass sie dir nicht von irgendwelchen Covid-Glücks-Rittern dein geistiges Eigentum gestohlen wird, ja? Und das ist ja das, was hier genau passiert ist in diesem Falle. Ähm,
Was ist dann passiert? Ähm ich glaube weniger als äh vierundzwanzig Stunden später. Ähm hat dann
Luca die Lizenz geändert und hat das ganze Ding unter GPL gestellt was jetzt auch wieder ganz interessant ist
denn damit ist es ja alles frei verwendbar, da sie aber nicht
alles unter diese GPL gestellt haben äh oder noch nicht alles veröffentlicht haben, sondern ihnen natürlich auch klar war, dass es ein wunderbarer PR-Move ist, äh ein Teil davon einfach Open Source zu stellen, weil dann natürlich alle wieder, Luka, geil ist jetzt Open Source und in der Öffentlichkeit
in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung sehr häufig immer noch, ja? Leider, ich kann's ja auch nicht erklären wieso.
Open Source als hinreichend wahrgenommen wird. Dass man also sagt, das ist jetzt gut, ne? Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Wer äh also es gibt ja auch Open Source Software, die nicht gut ist. Ähm.
Und äh ne, das aber wird eben weitläufig als Open Source ist
ein Qualitätsgarant wahrgenommen und deswegen ist es natürlich ein ein angenehmer Marketingscherz, mal eben irgendeine komische eigene Lizenz zu machen, dabei noch die die Rechte anderer zu verletzen und die haben sie ja übrigens vorher auch schon verletzt. Das muss man ja noch dazu sagen. Als sie das nämlich noch kommerziell
nicht Open Force hatten und nicht unter ihrer Analyzen, da war ja die wahre Verletzung äh,
der der GPL Rechte, äh des des äh Coders von dieser äh Library.
Ähm da haben sie sich dann wirklich, sage ich mal, auch mit dem letzten in der, in der Community,
verscherzt. Dann gab's noch diesen Schlüsselanhänger das ist auch immer wieder so ein Thema, wo dann gesagt wird, ah okay, was machen wir mit denen, die kein Handy haben, ja denen machen wir einen Schlüsselanhänger und,
in dem Schlüsselanhänger wird natürlich alle Dynamik wieder verloren, dann hast du nämlich einen statischen Code, den nur noch andere scannen können und nicht
du bei denen scannen kannst, das heißt, du hast auch nur die Hälfte der Funktionalität und so weiter und so fort. Haben sie aber auch noch gebaut. Da gab's dann jetzt auch wieder eine Schwachstelle,
und zwar die gleiche oder ähnlich gelagerte in der SMS-Verifikation, das heißt, du konntest dir im Prinzip auch einen nicht
ordentlich angemeldeten Schlüsselanhänger nehmen und damit quasi dann den den Luka-Check in vortäuschen. Also auch da haben sie's wieder nicht ordentlich gemacht.
Und äh so geht das da äh wirklich ähm also sagen wir aus einer professionellen Perspektive springen die gerade,
vom einen Fettnäpfchen ins nächste. Man fragt sich, wie die in so einem Fettnäpfchen überhaupt noch so viel Schwung holen können, um in das nächste zu.
Das ist aber schön gesagt. Also was ich beobachte, ist auch ähm diese ganzen Diskussionen um den äh veröffentlichen Code jetzt. Äh dass tatsächlich, also mir scheint da relativ viel,
gefunden zu werden von der Community. Ich beobachte das natürlich ja äh aus, also quasi als Unbeteiligte
und schaue halt, was die Diskussionen so verlaufen, was mir auf Twitter aufhaltenden Diskussionen, dass die Reaktionen von den Lukaleuten,
sehr dünn und auch sehr unsicher sind. Also ich habe jetzt mehrmals von Leuten.
Quasi als einfach externe den Code sie angeschaut haben, äh die haben mehrmals geschrieben, ich hab's Gefühl, ich verstehe euer Produkt besser als ihr das selber äh versteht.
Und mir erschien es auch so, dass die sehr viel genauer beschrieben haben, was die Schwachstellen sind und was da gerade Probleme sind, als die Leute selber.
Dazu was was sagen konnten und das finde ich wird bedenklich, also das ist ja ein Produkt, von dem uns.
Also das verkauft wurde als was, was fertig ist.
Je mehr ich davon sehe und von Leuten höre, die sich damit auskennen und den Code anschauen, desto klarer wird es eigentlich noch gar nicht fertig. Das ist in irgendeinem Status.
Wo wir bestenfalls äh Beta-Tester sind, nur dass das halt leider ein Produkt ist, was was sehr, sehr groß ausgerollt werden soll, Millionen von Bundesbürgern werden darin.
Ihre ihre Daten haben oder deren Daten werden damit verarbeitet.
Und plus Gesundheitsdaten Smooth hat neulich gesagt, das sind ja keine Gesundheitsdaten, aber das ich dachte, okay, dann äh beschäftigt euch einfach mit dem Thema ein bisschen mehr. Natürlich sind das auch Gesundheitsdaten, also spätestens, wenn jemand ein positives Testergebnis darüber teilt.
Ist dann spätestens sind's Gesundheitsdaten,
das alles in dem Zusammenhang, dass dass wir maximal Betatester sind jetzt gerade so ja also macht mir extreme Bauchschmerzen und ja erhöht auch mein äh,
Misstrauen sowohl gegenüber der App als eben leider auch den zuständigen Behörden, die entschieden haben, dass die jetzt äh genutzt wird.
Das ist äh,
traurigerweise leider ja in in der Schaffung digitaler Produkte ja zunehmend so, ne, dass sie als als Bananenprodukte äh in den Markt kommen, ne, reifen beim Kunden. Ähm.
Das ist ja leider ist das so, ist natürlich dann in diesem Kontext besonders kritischer Daten sehr schwierig, ne?
Und äh vor allem, wenn dann hier ja auch öffentliche Gelder gemolken werden, dann wird's natürlich ein bisschen komisch. Äh ich,
habe hier vorliegen eine Mail vom fünften März von äh Professor.
Christoph Meinel vom äh Hasso Plattner Institut, der sich da an die Doktorandinnen, die wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter und die Studentinnen widme, wendet,
und ihnen sagt, ja hier, was übrigens eine Ausgründung des HPI ist, ähm sucht Unterstützung bei der Weiterentwicklung und Anbindung von Luca, ähm was irgendwie,
die Kontaktverfolgung durch für die Gesundheitsämter äh automatisieren soll
und spannend hier, ne, bei der letzten Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz, bei Bundeskanzlerin Merkel, wurde ein Bundesweites Ausrollen abgestimmt, ja, das war mir zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht bekannt, das habe ich durch diese E-Mail gelernt. Jetzt ist jeder willkommen, der hier kurzfristig,
unterstützen und mitwirken kann und da kommt dann eben äh ja eine eine ganze Reihe an Stellenausschreibungen. Also der Eindruck, dass diese App
noch nicht fertig war, zumindest äh Anfang März. Äh ja, der ist klar, allerdings muss man jetzt auch
Das muss ich einschränkend sagen, Software ist nie fertig, ne? Das ist äh ist nun mal so. Ähm aber äh ja, zumindest ist ganz einfach an den Öffnungs äh Gepflogenheiten der Gastronomie seit ähm
Seit äh November eben auch absehbar, dass dieses Produkt noch keine Reifeprüfung hinter sich hat, ne.
Du hast es gerade so ein bisschen wie so ein Naturgesetz dargestellt, Software ist nie fertig und und immer öfter äh wird sie erst fertig, wenn quasi im im im Test mit dem aufm Markt, aber das das ist doch kein Naturgesetz, oder? Oder.
Es gibt einige wenige Software, von denen ähm irgendwelche C-Veteranen vermuten, dass sie vielleicht jetzt fertig sein könnte, ja.
Nee, ich meine, aber so fertig, dass man sich guten Gewissens.
Genau das.
Einsetzen kann, also klar fertig, das macht schon Sinn, dass es nicht fertig ist, aber so dass es so laufen muss wie bei Luca jetzt, auch wenn es immer öfter so läuft, aus deiner Beobachtung, das muss ja nicht so sein, oder?
Nein, nein, du hast absolut recht. Äh das war jetzt ein bisschen äh über überzogen. Äh Software ist nie hundert Prozent fertig, aber natürlich gibt es hier zwischen dem hundert Prozent und äh.
Äh es hat schon mal funktioniert, äh ein ein breites Spektrum und ähm Luca muss sich natürlich jetzt hier schon,
Frage gefallen lassen, dass das,
in dieser Form für Millionen verkauft wurde, ohne dass es hier mal ein den voluminar angemessenen äh Funktionstest gegeben hätte
ne? Das ist ja auch so, dass sie das sagen, wenn sie dann irgendwie so ein äh Vertrag mit einem Land haben, ja jetzt ziehen wir die Infrastruktur hoch.
Und natürlich wird da noch jeden Tag dran weitergekodet, ja? Ähm an Facebook wird auch den ganzen Tag irgendwo weiter gebastelt, ne? Das ist schon, also das meine ich mit
nie fertig. Aber klar, äh üblicherweise kauft man äh äh Produkte, deren äh Funktionen schon mal unter unter Normalbedingungen unter Beweis gestellt wurde.
Immer das sagen mir auch immer öfter Interviewpartnerinnen zu allen möglichen Themen, wenn's um äh Software geht. Ähm das genau, also das gespart wird.
Unter anderem an der Sicherheit, weil die ist halt teuer und aufwendig und es gibt einen enormen Druck.
Solche Dinge immer schneller auf den Markt zu bringen und dann genau on the go nochmal bisschen dran rumzuwerkeln. Und das, also das haben mir auch viele Forscherinnen und Forscher gesagt. Das ist natürlich was, was was gefährlich ist, ne, weil so entstehen.
Großen wo dann alle unsere Daten auf einmal wo auch immer die sind, ne? Öffentlich oder in den Händen von Kriminellen oder Spionen.
Das ist vielleicht was, wo man auch nochmal die Gesellschaft ein bisschen sensibilisieren müsste, dass.
Sicherheit kostet was, aber am Ende, wenn wenn's schief geht, kostet es natürlich noch viel mehr. Und die, man muss schon die ganze Rechnung aufmachen, um das zu verstehen.
Lass uns ähm vielleicht mal so gegen Ende ähm nochmal einen Blick auf
die kommende Version der Corona-Warn-App ähm machen. Die ist derzeit so in der Testversion releast. Ähm
nehmt da zwar dran teil, habt's aber jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert, aber es äh steht ja jetzt im Raum. Es ist auch angekündigt worden, schon im Blog, dass es eben eine vergleichbare Funktionalität ja geben wird. Ähm da denkt man natürlich jetzt als erstes mal an diesen, den wir jetzt sozusagen als als Studie, als Konzept schon mehrfach
haben, ist richtig sehe, gibt's aber.
Abweichungen davon. Was wissen wir denn äh zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt mh darüber, was die Corona-Warn-App quasi als
offizielle App ähm des Staates hier jetzt noch mit ins Feld führt und inwiefern.
Erledigt sich unter Umständen diese Luca-Diskussion dadurch auch schon.
Also ich kann ja mal anfangen, was ich äh weiß, hätte es ja in einer anderen Folge auch schon mal erzählt. Sie soll.
Jetzt sehr zeitnah eine Check-in-Funktion bekommen. Diese Check-in-Funktion soll.
Anonym sein, also es wird nicht äh es werden keine Namen äh oder Telefonnummern oder Orte gespeichert. Ähm.
Und sie soll ähm,
eben ähnlich alarmieren wie man es jetzt auch schon bei Kontakten macht. So, das ist sehr.
Viel von ist dabei, allerdings gibt es eben bei äh Crowd-Notifyer auch.
Überlegungen wie zum Beispiel die von Locations. Ja, wenn du jetzt nämlich beispielsweise eine,
ein Ort hast, ja? Äh Restaurant. Und,
jetzt könntest du sagen, okay, passt auf, der der QR-Code von unserem Restaurant, der ändert sich jetzt jeden Tag, ne, wäre völlig in Ordnung, aber da müsstest du dir darüber Gedanken machen, wie du den jetzt allen Leuten,
ähm zu zukommen lässt. Jetzt könnte es aber natürlich auch sein, dass du sagst, naja der braucht sich nicht mehr zu ändern, wir drucken den einfach aus und kleben den ähm,
an die Wand, ja? Ähm.
Das sind Dinge, die bei noch besser mit bedacht wurden. Eine andere Sache, wo ich es nicht weiß, wie es diese Corona äh Warn-App löst, ist.
Potenziell möchtest du ja äh vielleicht auch in einem Gespräch mit deiner äh contect Racerin beim Gesundheitsamt
einzelnen Situationen durchgehen und eine informierte Entscheidung treffen, ob du jetzt alarmierst oder nicht
Ne, es kann ja sein, dass du sagst, das hier waren äh gemeinsamer äh Spaziergang mit Maske. Das hier waren Besuch äh in dem und dem Restaurant und dass du dann eben äh,
unterschiedliche Entscheidungen triffst, da kommen ja auch so Sachen mit dazu wie, in welchen Zeitraum war ich überhaupt? Infektiös.
Ne? Also vor vierzehn Tagen ist potentiell äh kann was unterschiedliches bedeuten, je nachdem, wann dein Symptombeginn war und so weiter und so fort. Was ich jetzt hörte, ist, dass diese ähm.
Corona waren ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt, was ich hörte, ist kein gesichertes Wissen. Mit diesem Problem auf die Weise umgeht.
Dass diese Warnung eine insgesamt keinen so hohen Warnstatus haben wie jetzt. So eine rote, du hattest einen Risikokontakt
Risikokontakt mit einer Person, sondern eben nur so ein wahren Level haben, wie, okay, du warst an einem Ort dann und dann, ne, du weißt ja auch, wann du da warst und ähm äh mach dir da mal drüber Gedanken. Aber es es bleibt eben,
das Ding es ist eine wenn du irgendwo warst die Orte die du gescannt hast bleiben,
lokal auf deinem Handy. Du kannst auf jeden Fall auch anonyme Zusammenkünfte machen, also jede
Nutzerin der App kann spontan QR-Code generieren, alle anderen scannen den und nur die, die da waren, kennen diesen Code überhaupt und wenn keine der Personen, die diesen Code jemals meldet, dann
wird auch niemals überhaupt jemand erfahren, dass es ihn überhaupt gab. Und wenn die Leute erfahren, dass es ihn gab, wissen sie immer noch nicht, wofür er stand. Ja, also das wird alles äh genau in der Form.
Ähm auch äh übernommen in der ähm Corona-Warn-App und da,
haben wir ja gerade schon drüber gesprochen, dass es eben sehr überraschend ist, dass hier die.
Eine solche Weiterentwicklung gemacht wird, die ja erstmal sehr zu begrüßen scheint.
Allerdings die gesetzliche Grundlage nicht dafür geändert wurde, dass man das eben auch äh sinnvoll einsetzen kann. Ähm.
Interessanterweise hat das jetzt zu Diskussionen geführt, die mich dann auch äußerst überrascht haben. Das sind und und da habe ich auch wirklich den Eindruck, die,
die reagieren einfach nur noch auf irgendwas, was irgendwo steht und versuchen irgendwelche Feuer mit großen äh Schuhen auszutreten, weil sie dann gesagt haben, ja ja,
wir machen dann kompatible QR-Codes und diese Systeme von Luca und Corona-Warn-App, die sind nun mal fundamental inkompatibel. Das Einzige, was mir jetzt einfallen würde, wie man äh da den gleichen QR-Co
machen könnte, wäre, indem man quasi die Bit-Anzahl in dem QR-Code erhöht und einfach einen QR-Code nimmt, in dem sowohl in dem im Prinzip steht
Luca Doppelpunkt. Äh Semikolon
Corona-Warn-App-Doppelpunkt, ja, sodass man für dass man für beide diese beiden nicht kompatiblen QR-Codes von ihrem äh von ihrem,
Informationsgehalt einfach in einen schreibt. Ja, das wäre das einzige, was mir irgendwie ähm einleuchten würde.
So ein Schema reinschreibt, um sie auseinanderhalten zu können.
Ja klar, du kannst ja du kannst ja alles. Du kannst äh komplette äh die Bibel oder das Kapital in in QR-Co,
machen, der ist dann halt relativ groß, ja. Ähm insofern kannst du auch beides reinmachen, dann sind die kompatibel in einem QR-Code, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese Systeme in irgendeiner Form äh,
würden. Das das finde ich ein bisschen äh,
Ja, also das äh erscheint mir mal wieder irgendwie, dass irgendjemand vom Twittern mal kurz gerufen hat, können wir das auch noch machen.
Also es gibt ja den Verdacht, dass das auch eine Marketingmasche von Lukas ist, ne? So, dann.
Vielleicht sogar im Idealfall irgendwelche Querhäuse zu haben, dass dann quasi Corona-Warn-App-Nutzer drauf gebracht werden, hey.
Kannst ja auch die Luca-App runterladen so in die Richtung äh oder eben einfach, um zu sagen, hey, sind wir eh schon kompatibel mit den Koalkohols, es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund, noch irgendeine andere Lösung äh aufm Markt oder zuzulassen oder in deinem Restaurant zu benutzen oder so,
Ich glaube eigentlich schon, ich weiß auch nicht, wie es genau gemacht wird, aber ich glaube, da gibt's gibt's eine Lösung, die die schon technisch schon OK ist,
jetzt keine Datenaustausch zwischen diesen beiden Apps. Ich sehe das wirklich eher unter diesem,
Marketingding, weil letztlich ein Argument wär auch, wir wollen halt ja nicht so viel QR-Codes über haben, aber ich meine, hey, ob da nur eins oder zwei oder drei QR-Codes in der Kneipe hängen, ist ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen egal. Also da stehen mir die.
Dringlichkeit eigentlich nicht, nicht, nicht so groß.
Was ich ähm interessant finde, dass du gesagt hast, dass man genau die Warn-App äh aus äh aus aufbohrt oder erweitert, aber die restliche Grundlage nicht ändert, dafür, dass das reicht.
Und das finde ich interessant, weil hier ganz viele Leute sagen, genau das, ja, wir brauchen doch die Luca-App, weil das Gesetz so ist. Und ähm so ein Gesetz kann man aber natürlich ändern.
Sätze müssen sogar geändert werden, auch für die Luca-App, weil bisher schreiben die in verschiedenen Bundesländern verschiedene Sachen vor, in manchen muss man die Telefonnummer erheben, in manchen auch die Adresse
und alle generell wird vorgeschrieben, dass der Wirt eine sogenannte Plausibilitätsprüfung machen muss, also die Kneipe muss gucken, dass sich eben äh jemand, dass das hier jemand, der sagt, ich bin Donald Duck nochmal anspricht und sagt, hey komm, das glauben wir nicht, schreib mal deinen echten Namen hin,
und das geht ja gar nicht, ne? Mit Luca, weil natürlich auch dann das der Ort, also die, die Kneipe zum Beispiel an sich gar nicht mehr sehen kann, was derjenige angegeben hat. Also das heißt.
Diese Landes Coronaverordnungen müssen sowieso angepasst werden, auch dass man Luca nutzen kann.
Also könnte man sie auch anpassen, damit eine also eine anonyme Version ausreicht, eine anonyme Warnung ausreicht und dass es eben nicht mehr bloß Gesundheitsamt gehen muss.
Da gibt's auch, also die Maritansen zum Beispiel, Landesdatenschützerin von Schleswig-Holstein, die hat das schon gefordert und es ist ja auch total sinnvoll.
Da wundere ich mich manchmal, wie dann Leute äh so davon ausgehe, ja es steht da so im Gesetz, also es ist für immer und ewig der Fall. Man könnte ja auch sagen, ne, also das Gesetz.
Gemerkt, es gibt andere Wege sinnvoller zu machen, weil kein so ein Gesetz einfach ändern. Das finde ich eher normal Punkt, der oft vergessen wird.
Eine kleine Ergänzung. Du hast gerade gesagt, es gibt Hinweise, dass die versuchen, das gegenseitig zu empfehlen,
gehe davon aus, dass du diese Werbe äh interne Werbepräsentation von Luca auch hast. Da steht's ja sogar auf der, auf der Folie drei drauf, ne? Äh,
Corona-Warn-App Wunsch Doppelpunkt Verweis auf Luca für die Anwesenheitsdokumentation und im Gegentausch
sie an bei jedem Check-In können Nutzer auf die CWA verwiesen werden, also die die wollen da quasi so ein so ein Werbekartell machen, ne? Also wenn du für mich wirbst, werde ich für dich äh außerdem habe ich noch einen Insta-Kanal und so, ne.
Broschür oder in den Verträgen, mit den Bundesländern steht das wohl auch drin.
Dass die Werbung für Luca machen müssen und darauf aufmerksam machen müssen. Also dieses taucht immer wieder auf, ne? Marketing steht einfach an allererster Stelle.
Das können sie äh angefochten, richtig gut. Was sie sonst gut können ist ein bisschen unklar.
Und das kann der Staat halt wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Also das das letzte halbe Jahr eigentlich für die Öffentlichkeit
äh dieser App nichts getan wurde. Ja, man hat so am Anfang ein paar Fußballer beklebt und ein paar Plakate aufgestellt und das war's dann im Wesentlichen. Aber das mal so aktiv irgendwie ähm.
Permanent diese Geschichte erzählt wird, warum es nützlich sein kann und dass umso mehr Leute mitmachen, ja, wo sind die Werbespots im äh Fernsehen? Wo wo ist äh das permanente äh Wiederholen, dieses Aspekt der Merk
man einfach, dass obwohl sie am Anfang.
Mehr oder weniger durch Zufall ein paar Dinge richtig gemacht haben, sie gar nicht verstanden haben, was sie da jetzt eigentlich für eine Chance haben. Nämlich mit einer App auch so ein äh auch über die ursprüngliche Funktion hinaus. Wäre ja die CWA.
Wunderbar gewesen, immer darüber nachzudenken, okay, das ist die eine App, mit mit der wir quasi diese Krise kommunizieren. Nein, aber dann ist natürlich die die aktuellen Regeln, die sind dann natürlich dann in der Nina App,
aber nicht in der Corona-Warn-App. Und die, ja, warum ja keine Ahnung, warum. Hätte man aber machen können,
oder eben äh relativ früh auch schon eben diese ähm diese Funktion, die ja,
lange schon besprochen wird, auch zu planen und immer wieder darauf hinzuweisen, dass es diese App ist. Warum darf ein Laden in Deutschland,
öffnen, ohne nicht einen Standard, den A vier Zettel äh des Landes aushängen zu müssen, ja, der einfach sozusagen vorgeschrieben ist mit Muss, wenn du wenn du öffnest, muss dieser Zettel an der Tür sein.
Da steht drauf bla, bla, bla, das ist die aktuelle Situation. Das ist die Webseite, über die du dich über die aktuelle Situation äh informieren kannst. Und übrigens installiere dir mal die Corona-Warn-App.
Hätte man machen können. Wurde aber nicht gemacht,
und ja, sie hätten noch nicht mal was gekostet. Also es war wirklich, wäre wirklich äh kostenlose äh Werbung überall gewesen und man hätte jetzt sozusagen noch mehr Installationen geboren.
Die äh sich jetzt noch verstärken würden. In dem Moment, wo man aber jetzt diese andere App noch mit ins Feld führt, dann äh wird also nicht nur erstmal wieder viel
Vertrauen eingerissen, weil die Leute sich ja auch fragen, ah jetzt brauchen wir noch eine eine andere App. Das hat wohl mit der Corona-Warn-App nicht funktioniert
Die denken ja nicht über diese unterschiedlichen Funktionalitäten nach, ja, es ist sozusagen wird wahrgenommen wie die App, die uns retten soll.
So, das heißt, es kommt irgendwie eine andere App, aber da muss also erst kommen, bis das funktioniert, dann hat die andere ja wohl nicht funktioniert. So, dann wissen die Leute auch nicht so richtig,
dazwischen so da äh unterscheiden und denken, das ist so wie das Gleiche und die Heiße ist vielleicht anders oder so. Also so so eine intensive Auseinandersetzung, wie wir das jetzt hier führen, äh machen ja die allerwenigsten und das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Das ist die allerwenigsten Leute tun. Und
Von daher verpufft jetzt sozusagen gleich auf mehreren Ebenen was. Erstmal man hätte mit dem Geld, was man in diese Luca App reinstecken könnt, ja?
Bei dieser Corona-Warn-App sehr viel mehr erreichen können. Man hätte die ganzen Rechte daran besessen.
Man hätte das klar steuern können und vor allem auch immer wieder klar kommunizieren können, dass jetzt hier nicht noch irgendeinen Hintergedanke dabei ist,
bei dieser Luka-App ist bei Design ein anderer Hintergedanke. Dahinter ist es nämlich ein Start-up, was versucht, irgendwie eine App im Markt zu bekommen. Und ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass der erste Gedanke, wenn irgendwie der letzte Deutsche geimpft ist, ähm bei diesem Team ist.
Pandemie ist vorbei, dann lass mal die App einstellen.
Unbedingt vom Markt nehmen, nachdem wir, was weiß ich, wie viel Millionen Installationen haben, löschen wir die jetzt aus dem App Store. Das ist eine richtig geile Idee.
Damit gewinnen wir noch Investoren. Nee, wird nicht funktionieren. Also
das das finde ich, ist das eigentliche, unterliegende Kommunikationsdesaster äh äh und reiht sich wieder schön ein in in diese fortwährende Dauergeschichte der Ver,
Chancen der Digitalisierung in Deutschland, die einfach sehr viel damit zu tun hat, dass wir diese diese inneren Kompetenz nicht haben,
Also du kannst die Leute, du kannst die Politik wirklich auch wirklich mit der Stirn auf den Stein hauen und, und, und sie merken, keine Einschläge, weil sie einfach überhaupt nicht verstehen, womit sie's zu tun haben.
Also sie wissen überhaupt gar nicht, welche welche Werkzeuge sie hier ins Leben rufen, sondern das sind halt immer alles solche Wunderheil, Schlangenöl äh Instrumente, die ins Feld,
worden. Ja, von denen ihr irgendjemand erklärt hat, ey hier, das ist total wenn du das aufträgst, dann, dann, dann, dann geht alles wieder weg,
und ja und so so ist es ja auch kommuniziert worden.
Und das Spannende ist, das ist ja bei der Corona-Warn-App aus Versehen richtig gemacht haben, ne, weil hier ist es so, äh ne, die die Bedingung ist erfüllt, dass es,
eigentlich keinen anderen Anwendungszweck dafür gibt, ja? Sie hat auch keine ähm keine Verwertungsmöglichkeiten, die darüber hinausgehend monetärer Art und.
Der Bund hat die Hoheit über die Entwicklung, ja? Wir haben ja bei dir in UKW das Interview mit äh einigen der Programmierer auch gehört und es ist klar,
SAP und Deutsche Telekom sind hier erstmal nur ausführende. Ja, das.
Die sind, äh die entwickeln das Ding überhaupt nicht weiter von sich aus oder machen irgendwas, sondern äh denen wird gesagt, wir beauftragen jetzt folgendes Feature und dann könnt ihr das machen, ne. Aber äh die haben keinerlei äh.
Oder Gestaltungsrecht, ja? Die haben natürlich Mitspracherecht und können sagen, pass mal auf, das hier ist sinnvoll, das hier nicht. Und ähm ich verrate vielleicht auch nicht zu viel, wenn ich jetzt mal vorsichtig andeute, dass die
Entwickler der äh Corona-Warn-App sich natürlich auch gefreut hätten, äh das Projekt ähm.
Oder einige Entwickler der Corona-Warnapps sich vielleicht auch gefreut hätten, das Projekt
ähm aktiver weiter gestalten zu dürfen, als es ihnen dann in den weiteren Monaten äh beauftragt wurde.
Ich meine, das ist ein Punkt, auf den hast du ja auch schon, glaube ich, tatsächlich im Oktober, November hingewiesen, ne, dass die Corona-Warn-App mehr können, könnte und sollte. Ähm.
Und es wurde, na ja, ob's verschlafen wurde, ist eine Frage, in die andere könnte auch gut sein, dass es dass es einfach bewusst erstmal liegengelassen wurde, ne, weil ja offenbar, wie er schon sagt, der das Bedürfnis nicht so groß ist für die Corona-Warn-App Werbung zu machen und dafür.
Einzutreten,
Finde ich übrigens auch ein starkes Argument gegen all dieses, äh bei der Datenschutz bremst uns jetzt aus und Leute sterben, was was ich wirklich finde. Ähm nee, also es gab eine Datenschutzfreundliche Lösung schon im Oktober oder November, die wurde nur einfach nicht äh vorangetrieben. Die wäre jetzt schon lange fertig,
jetzt dann ja auch ab.
Übernächste Woche soweit. Ähm aber ja, dann wurde halt von der Luca-App und äh dem Lauten äh Marketinggeschrei von Smudo über überholt, sodass sogar die Politik.
Vergessen hat, dass wir dadurch noch ein was eigenes haben, wo schon viel Geld und äh Liebe drinsteckt. Und das ist natürlich besonders tragisch.
Das sind doch glaube ich schöne Schlussworte, oder.
Das äh wollte ich jetzt auch gerade betonen. Ähm.
Eva. Ich denke, an der Stelle kann man das Problem erstmal ähm wieder in einen Podcast gepackt äh weglegen. Ähm vielen Dank, dass du hier mitgemacht hast.
Euch auch vielen Dank. War spannend und immer interessant mit euch zu reden.
Wir sind gespannt auf deinen dritten Artikel.
Also ja, Hinweise gerne zu mir.
Das Thema ist noch nicht ganz ausgestanden. Also ein paar äh Auseinandersetzungen, paar Aspekte werden hier sicherlich noch aufkommen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, dann äh machen wir einfach Schluss für heute, weil jetzt auch schon über zwei äh Stunden. Ich hoffe, das hat euch mal wieder weitergebracht. War heute mal eine Monothematische Sendung. Das kennt ihr schon von uns. Ab und zu machen wir das.
Noch eine Housekeeping ähm Hinweis, ich äh habe übers Osterwochenende ein bisschen gebastelt und es gibt jetzt die,
unserer Sendung, die wir immer automatisch erzeugen, äh etwas konsumfähiger zum Download, findet ihr auf unserer,
Seite, also da, falls ihr äh was sozusagen zum archivieren runterladen wollt, äh gibt's die ganzen Transkripte ähm als HTML Datei äh für eure Festplatte. Dann könnt ihr dann äh schneller suchen,
Die Transkripte gab es schon immer im Webplay, aber jetzt sind sie sozusagen auch leichter externalisierbar.
Und äh die sind auch in Maschinen lesbarer Form verfügbar für äh euch Nerds, die Lust haben, da vielleicht mit ein bisschen,
rumzubasteln. Nochmal der Hinweise sind automatisch erzeugte Transkripte, ne? Also da steht auch Quatsch drin.
Also nicht nur der Quatsch, den wir so von uns geben, sondern vielleicht halt auch noch so erfunden da äh Quatsch, noch mehr Quatsch sozusagen
Könnt's auch noch was bringen, ne. Aber um mal schnell Stellen wieder zu finden oder zu schauen, wo ist denn das eigentlich? Ihr könnt dann auch einfach äh in diesem HTML dann eine beliebige Textstelle äh klicken und seid dann auch sofort wieder auf der äh Webseite gleich an der richtigen Stelle, wo äh geredet wird und dann könnt ihr das dann nach,
Also, viele Möglichkeiten, noch mehr Zeit mit Logbuch zu verbringen, als ohnehin schon. Ja, das war's, oder Linus?
Damit sind wir am Ende. Danke, Eva.
Danke. Tschau.
Und wir hören uns beim nächsten Mal.
Genau, tschüss, bis bald.